Thank you for listening to The Rest Is History. For weekly bonus episodes, ad-free listening, early access to series, and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to therestishistory.com and join the club. That is therestishistory.com. Bertier is no more. His head is nothing more than a mutilated stump separated from his body. A man, oh gods, a man, a barbarian, tears out his heart from his palpitating viscera. He is avenging himself on a monster, his hands dripping with blood. He holds up the steaming heart under the eyes of the men of peace assembled in this august tribunal of humanity. Tyrants, cast your eyes on this terrible spectacle.
感谢您收听《历史余味》。如需每周额外剧集、无广告收听、抢先观看系列节目以及加入我们备受喜爱的聊天社区，请前往 therestishistory.com 加入俱乐部。网址是 therestishistory.com。贝尔蒂埃已不复存在。他的头颅不过是一截从躯干上分离出来的残缺断桩。一个男人，哦，天哪，一个男人，一个野蛮人，从他那还在颤动的内脏中掏出了他的心脏。他正在向一个怪物复仇，双手滴着鲜血。他在这座庄严的人类法庭上，在和平人士的注视下，举起了那颗还在冒着热气的心脏。暴君们，睁大眼睛看看这可怕的景象吧。
Shudder and see how you and yours will be treated. This body, so delicate and so refined, bathed in perfumes, is horribly dragged in the mud and over the cobblestones. Despots and ministers, your reign is over. Frenchmen, you are exterminating tyrants. Your hatred is revolting, frightful, but you will, at last, be free. Think how ignominious it is to live as slaves. Think what good, what satisfaction, what happiness awaits you and your children when the august and holy Temple of Liberty will have set up its temple for you. That was the journalist Élisée Lustalo writing in his paper Révolution de Paris,
颤抖吧，看看你们和你们的同类将会受到怎样的对待。这具曾经如此精致、如此高贵、沐浴在香水中的躯体，如今正被极其恐怖地拖过泥泞和鹅卵石路。专制者和大臣们，你们的统治结束了。法国人，你们正在铲除暴君。你们的仇恨令人作呕、令人恐惧，但你们终将获得自由。想想作为奴隶生活是多么屈辱。想想当庄严神圣的自由之殿为你们建立起它的殿堂时，等待着你们和你们孩子的是怎样的美好、满足与幸福。这是记者埃利泽·吕斯塔洛在他创办的《巴黎革命报》上写下的文字，
which he launched in the fateful month of July 1789. And he is describing with some relish the lynching of the royal official Berthier de Sauvigny a week after the fall of the Bastille on the 14th of July. And Dominic, the fall of the Bastille on the 14th of July. And Dominic, the fall of the Bastille, it is viewed by many people in France and across the world as a moment of liberation. It's the National Day of France, of course, and it is celebrated and always has been celebrated by many, many people as a moment when the chains of tyranny and despotism are broken. And that is the reading that you have chosen to mark this glorious moment when the sunshine
他在1789年那个决定命运的七月创办了这份报纸。他正带着某种快意描述着巴士底狱于7月14日陷落一周后，王室官员贝尔蒂埃·德·索维尼被私刑处死的情景。多米尼克，巴士底狱于7月14日陷落，在法国乃至全世界许多人眼中，这被视为一个解放的时刻。当然，这是法国的国庆日，它一直以来都被许多许多人庆祝，视为暴政和专制的枷锁被打破的时刻。而这正是你选择用来纪念这个光辉时刻的读物，当自由的阳光
of liberty is let in on the dank darkness of royal despotism. Well, hello, everybody. Yes, Tom, when you say I've chosen, that passage actually is quoted by Simon Sharma in his book Citizens. And Sharma's argument in that book, which was published in 1989, the bicentenary of the revolution, was that violence, horrific violence, was at the heart of the French Revolution from the very beginning. That it was one of the great motors of the revolution and that historians had tended to downplay it. And I think when you read that passage and you read what happens to Berthier de Sauvigny, and indeed you read what happens to so many people in that period in July 1789 surrounding the fall of the Bastille,
照进了王室专制那阴冷黑暗的角落。好吧，大家好。是的，汤姆，你说是我选择的，那段文字实际上是西蒙·沙马在他的著作《公民》中引用的。沙马在那本出版于1989年（即革命两百周年）的书中的观点是，暴力，那种可怕的暴力，从一开始就是法国大革命的核心。它是革命的伟大动力之一，而历史学家们往往倾向于淡化它。我想当你读到那段文字，读到贝尔蒂埃·德·索维尼的遭遇，甚至读到1789年7月巴士底狱陷落前后那段时间里发生在许多人身上的事情时，
so the few days before and then the week or so afterwards, I think it's actually quite hot. It is a moment of utopian celebration, liberty, equality, fraternity. There's an awful lot of quite horrific bloodshed that if it had happened in different circumstances, you would say unbelievably repellent. And actually, of course, there'll be lots of people listening to this podcast who say, oh, you know, Dominic is taking far too harsh a line.
也就是在那几天之前以及之后的一周左右，我认为这其实相当火爆。这是一个乌托邦式的庆典时刻，自由、平等、博爱。其中有大量相当可怕的流血事件，如果发生在不同的环境下，你会说这令人难以置信地反感。当然，实际上会有很多收听这个播客的人说，哦，你知道，多米尼克采取的立场太严厉了。
And in a way, you can say that what you think of the fall of the Bastille expresses your political identity. You tell me what you think of July 1789, and I have a pretty good shot at guessing your modern day politics. That's true, do you think, Tom? I think it is. I mean, it's clearly true in France, although I suppose in France, the attitude is generally more positive, isn't it? But there has been a kind of a lengthy tradition that views the revolution as a mistake in France. But in Britain, we've already talked about this, the division in opinion between Edmund Burke, who sees it as a blood- France. Yeah. But in Britain, we've already talked about this, the division in opinion between Edmund Burke,
在某种程度上，你可以说你对巴士底狱陷落的看法表达了你的政治认同。你告诉我你对1789年7月的看法，我就能相当准确地猜出你的现代政治立场。你觉得这是真的吗，汤姆？我认为是的。我的意思是，这在法国显然是真的，尽管我想在法国，这种态度通常更积极，不是吗？但在法国，有一种长期的传统认为革命是一个错误。但在英国，我们已经讨论过这一点，埃德蒙·伯克（他将其视为一场血腥的灾难）与托马斯·潘恩（他将其视为一个解放的时刻，就像法国人所认为的那样）之间的观点分歧。我的意思是，他最终
who sees it as a blood-spattered disaster. Yeah. And Tom Paine, who sees it as a moment of liberation, much as the French do. I mean, he ends up
成为了法国公民，不是吗？他确实是。但在最终入狱并面临处决威胁之前。但是，我的意思是，关于巴士底狱的流血事件是否
becoming a French citizen, doesn't he? He does indeed. Before ending up in prison and threatened with execution. But, I mean, this question of whether the bloodshed at the Bastille
预示了恐怖时期的流血事件，或者说这个解放的时刻是否预示了对人类和政治的一种新理解。我的意思是，这是一个非常根本的分歧。是的。沙马是怎么说的？恐怖时期不过是1789年的延续，只是死亡人数更多而已。
foreshadows the bloodshed of the terror, or whether the moment of liberation foreshadows the sense of a new understanding of humanity and of politics. I mean, that is a really fundamental division. Yes. What does Sharma say? The terror was just 1789 with a higher body count.
是的，所以他的论点是，这不是一个漏洞，而是系统本身。是的，完全正确。但当时也有很多历史学家在评论沙马的书。沙马并不是唯一撰写关于革命历史的学者。有很多人说，不，不，他忽略了真正进步的一面，他只是在重炒埃德蒙·伯克的冷饭。事实上，革命确实有很多进步的后果。我们将在本系列节目中深入探讨这一点。
Yeah, so the argument would be that it's not a bug, it's the system. Yes, exactly. But there are then a lot of historians, and even at the time, reviewing Sharma's book. Sharma's not the only historian to write about the revolution. And there were lots who said, no, no, he's missing the genuine progressive, you know, he's just reheating Edmund Burke. And actually, the revolution had lots of progressive consequences. And we'll get into that in the course of the series.
但今天让我们深入挖掘1789年7月到底发生了什么。让我们从上周的剧集开始讲起。听众们会记得，当时由于糟糕的天气、歉收、饥荒，以及随着人们开始挨饿而席卷法国大部分地区的恐惧，产生了一场社会危机。还有一场可以追溯到几十年前的财政和政治危机，与法国政府为支付对外战争而背负债务有关。它的政治体制，不像英国那样，并没有真正允许他们这样做的机制。法国一直处于破产边缘。路易十六召集了三级会议，这个由平民、贵族和教会组成的伟大集会，随后演变成了一个国民
But let's dig today into what really happened in July 1789. And let's start by picking up from last week's episodes. So listeners will remember there was a social crisis born of the horrendous weather, the bad harvest, the hunger, the frustration, the fear that has swept through so much of France as people begin to starve. There's a financial and political crisis that goes back for decades to do with the French government running up debts to pay for its foreign wars. Its political system, unlike say Britain's, not really having a mechanism that allows them to do that. France has been on the verge of bankruptcy. Louis XVI has recalled the Estates General, this great gathering of the commons, the lords and the church, which has then morphed into a national
议会，并基本上采取了从君主制手中夺取主权的行动。我们上次结束时提到，2万名军队正从边境向巴黎移动，其中许多是瑞士人或德语使用者。他们被巴黎大部分民众所恐惧和憎恨，他们正在向首都推进，在巴黎街头引发了恐慌。当你进入1789年7月初时，有一种感觉，一切都在向顶峰积聚。食品价格上涨，街头的恐慌，偏执的感觉一直在增长。因为众所周知，面包价格在7月14日达到了顶峰，不是吗？确实如此，大约15苏，
assembly and basically made a move to take sovereignty from the monarchy. And we ended last time, 20,000 troops are moving towards Paris from the frontiers, many of them Swiss or German speakers. So feared and hated by much of the Parisian population, they are advancing on the capital, triggering panic in the streets of population. They are advancing on the capital, triggering panic in the streets of Paris. And there's a sense when you get to the beginning of July 1789, everything is building towards a peak. The food prices are rising, the panic on the streets, the sense of paranoia is growing all the time. Because famously, the bread price reaches its pinnacle on the 14th of July, doesn't it? It does indeed, about 15 sous,
而平时大约是8苏。换句话说，面包价格翻了一番。对很多人来说，这意味着赤贫。生活成本危机。生活成本危机加剧了。在这一点上，尽管生活成本危机是由天灾（即天气）引起的，但很多人已经在寻找替罪羊了。这确实是整个法国大革命故事的一个真正主题。
having been normally about 8 sous. So in other words, bread has doubled. And for a lot of people, that means destitution. Cost of living crisis. Cost of living crisis with knobs on. And a lot of people at this point, even though that cost of living crisis is driven by acts of God, which is to say the weather, people are already looking for scapegoats. And that is a real theme of the entire French Revolutionary story.
所以，一位新国民议会的代表，未来公共安全委员会的成员，贝特朗·巴雷尔，在6月19日说，粮食短缺是人民公敌、人类公敌的灾难性计划的结果，他们需要被发现、威慑和惩罚。这又是一个对未来事件的预演。但绝妙的是，人民的英雄，出人意料地，竟然是一位银行家。这在今天可不多见。没错。
So a guy, a deputy in the new National Assembly, a future member of the Committee of Public Safety, or Bertrand Barrère, said on the 19th of June that the food shortage was the result of the disastrous projects of the enemies of the people, enemies of humanity, and they need to be discovered, intimidated, and punished. And there again, a preview of what's to come. But brilliantly, the people's hero, rather unexpectedly, is a banker. Not what you see today. That's right.
所以这就是我们上次谈到的那个人，雅克·内克，财政大臣，一位瑞士新教徒。他是大多数法国公众视为救星的那个人。但正如我们上次所说，路易对内克失去了信心，在7月11日星期六下午五点，内克和他的妻子乘马车永远离开了凡尔赛。他被国王以一种非常卑劣的方式解雇了。内克正要坐下来吃晚饭时，收到了一张纸条，告诉他必须立即离开法国，而且不能经过巴黎。他去了布鲁塞尔。实际上，内克随后做了一件事，汤姆，
So this is somebody, again, we talked about last time, Jacques Necker, the finance minister, a Swiss Protestant. He's the one person that most of the French public view as their saviour. But as we said last time louis has been losing confidence in necker and at five o'clock on saturday the 11th of july necker and his wife leave versailles for good in a coach he has been sacked by the king in a very kind of underhand means necker was about to sit down to have dinner when he got a note telling him he had to leave france immediately and not go via paris He goes to Brussels. And actually, Necker then does something, Tom,
我认为这表现得非常令人钦佩。如果能对内克有一个修正主义的看法会很好。但内克第二天到达布鲁塞尔，他给荷兰银行家霍普写了一封信。他对他们说，我拿出两百万英镑的个人资金作为向法国人民运送粮食的担保。即使我已经被解雇了，我仍然愿意为这两百万英镑的个人资金作为向法国人民运送粮食的担保，即使我已经被解雇了，我仍然愿意承担这两百万英镑。我的意思是，他是个相当不错的人。令人钦佩。是的。现在国王的顾问们，他们在星期六解雇了他。他们以为自己很聪明。他们认为因为国民议会在星期天不开会，就不会有直接的反应，他们
which I think shows very admirable. It'd be nice to sort of have a revisionist view of Necker. But Necker gets to Brussels the next day, and he writes a letter to the Dutch banker's hope. And he says to them, I put up two million pounds in my own money as security for grain shipments to the people of France. Even though I have been fired, I'm still good for the two million pounds in my own money as security for grain shipments to the people of France, even though I have been fired, I'm still good for the two million pounds. I mean, he's a pretty decent fellow. Admirable. Yeah. Now the King's advisors, they'd sacked him on a Saturday. They thought they were being very clever. They thought that because the National Assembly wouldn't meet on the Sunday, there wouldn't be an immediate reaction and they
因此能够控制局面。但他们没有预料到，他们没有考虑周全，因为在巴黎的星期天，很多人显然是不工作的，他们走上了街头。有很多游客，有从乡下进城的人。这些人中的许多人聚集在所谓的皇家宫殿，这是城市的一部分，一个由拱廊、咖啡馆和商店组成的巨大建筑群，它不在国王的管辖之下，而是在奥尔良公爵的管辖之下。对。我们谈过那个，不是吗？
would therefore be able to manage it. But what they didn't bargain for, they didn't think it through because on Sunday in Paris, a lot of people obviously are not working and they have taken to the streets. There are a lot of sightseers, there are peasants who've come in from the countryside to kind of go into the city. And a lot of these people have gathered at what's called the Palais Royal, which is a part of the city, a great complex of sort of arcades and cafes and shops that is under the jurisdiction, not of the king, but of the Duke of Orléans. Right. And we've talked about that, haven't we?
我们谈到，例如，当我们谈论对玛丽·安托瓦内特的辱骂时，很多这种辱骂来自凡尔赛内部，来自王室内部的派系。而奥尔良公爵，他是路易的堂兄。虽然他完全致力于这些事业，我的意思是，他最终会投票支持路易的死刑。是的。我认为奥尔良公爵不是一个好人。我的意思是，在某种意义上，即使是现在，也有一种轻微的内部王室
And talked about how, for instance, when we were talking about the abuse leveled at Marie Antoinette, that a lot of this is coming from factions within Versailles, within the royal family. And the Duke of Orléans, he is Louis' cousin. And although he's absolutely committed to the causes, I mean, he will end up voting for Louis' death. Yeah. He's not a good man, I think, the Duke of Orléans. I mean, there's a sense in which even now there is a slight quality of kind of the internal royal
派系斗争的味道。是的，我想是的。但这显然已经完全失控了。完全失控了，是的。所以皇家宫殿里聚集了巨大的人群，成千上万的人，中午左右消息传来，内克被解雇了。人群非常愤怒，他们都在大喊大叫，而且有一种传统，就是演讲者站出来
faction fight going on. Yeah, I think so. But it's obviously spiraling massively out of that. Massively out of control, yeah. So there are huge crowds that have assembled in the Palais Royal, thousands of people, and the news arrives by about midday that Necker has been sacked. And the crowds are very cross and angry, and they're all shouting, and there would be a tradition of kind of orators standing up
在街角发表即兴演讲之类的。到三点左右，一大群人，据说有成千上万，聚集在一家特定的咖啡馆周围，一个年轻人站在桌子上对着人群大喊。它叫福伊咖啡馆。这个年轻人对于读过希拉里·曼特尔的书《更安全的地方》的人来说会非常熟悉，因为他确实是那本书的英雄。他叫卡米尔·德穆兰。他26岁。他来自皮卡第。
and giving impromptu speeches on the street corners and things. By about three o'clock, a large crowd, it's said to be thousands of people, has gathered around one particular cafe, where a young man is standing on a table shouting at the crowd. The Cafe Foy, it's called. And this young man will be very familiar to people who've read Hilary Mantel's book, A Place of Greater Safety, because he's really the hero of that book. And he's called Camille Desmoulins. He's 26 years old. He came from Picardy.
他是那种稍微被宠坏的副中校的儿子，他把他送到巴黎接受教育。在巴黎的路易大帝中学，卡米尔成了很多听众肯定会熟悉的一个人的好朋友，马克西米连·罗伯斯庇尔。所以他们确实是一对形影不离的组合。德穆兰不是三级会议的代表，但他非常属于那一类人。所以他痴迷于罗马人，痴迷于西塞罗，痴迷于自由，痴迷于美德。他写过一首诗，一首献给三级会议的颂歌。所以他是一个非常桑德布鲁克式的人物。谢谢你，汤姆。是的，太棒了。完全正确。
He's the kind of slightly spoiled son of a lieutenant colonel who had sent him to Paris for his education. And at the Lycée Louis-Lecron in Paris, Camille had become great pals with a man whose name will definitely be familiar to a lot of listeners, Maximilien Robespierre. So they're a real sort of inseparable duo. And Desmoulins is not a deputy at the Estates General, but he's very much of that ilk. So he's obsessed with the Romans, with Cicero, with liberty, with virtue. He's written a poem, an ode to the Estates General. So he's a very Sandbrook figure. Thank you, Tom. Yeah, great. Exactly.
他有点像雪莱，不是吗？他是。他是一个想成为雪莱的人。诗人是世界未被承认的立法者。完全正确。他是一个年轻、长发的理想主义者。他是我讨厌的那种男人，汤姆。我期待着你保持公正。好吧，沙马说他是那种在皇家宫殿流行的捶胸顿足、催人泪下的演说的倡导者。他的风格，一种战斗的美德基调，混合了在沙龙和舞台上的新古典主义历史画中所体现的爱国殉道精神，所以你绝对可以认出这种类型，1968年在纽约哥伦比亚大学，或者在巴黎，或者在伦敦政治经济学院，他会是第一个参加静坐示威的人，或者类似的事情，或者1848年，我的意思是，他就在那个传统的开端，不是吗？长发诗人投掷鹅卵石的传统。是的，他绝对是。所以，德穆兰站在桌子上对大家说，你知道，内克被踢出去了。
He's a kind of Shelley, isn't he? He is. He's a wannabe Shelley. Poets as the unacknowledged legislators of the world. Exactly. He's a young, long-haired idealist. He's everything I dislike in a man, Tom. I look forward to you being fair. Well, Sharma says he's an exponent of the breast-beating,
你，这个国家，我们受到了侮辱。他说，拿起武器，拿起武器。据说他从树上抓下叶子，说，让我们都戴上绿色帽徽，那是希望的颜色。他戴着这些叶子。所以那是一个没有成功的营销策略。不，但当时每个人都说，哦，太棒了。喜欢它。每个人都在喊好，人们在亲吻他，也在亲吻彼此。他们拿那种绿色的丝带，或者拿树枝或叶子之类的东西，
sob-provoking declamation then in vogue at the Palais Royal. His style, a tone of virtue militant, mingled with the patriotic martyrdom exemplified in neoclassical history paintings in the salon and on the stage so you can absolutely the type in 1968 at columbia in new york or in paris or the london school of economics he'd have been the first one to do the sit-in or whatever or 1848 I mean, he's there at the beginning of that tradition, isn't he? Of the long-haired poets throwing cobblestones. Yes, absolutely he is. So, Desmoulins stands on the table and he says to everybody, you know, NECA has been kicked out.
任何绿色的东西。然后他们走上首都的街头，从皇家宫殿走上首都的街头。他们中的一些人穿着丧服，为内克的离职哀悼。
You, the nation, we've been insulted. And he says, aux armes, aux armes, to arms, to arms. And supposedly he grabs the leaves from a tree and he says, let us all take a green cockade, the color of hope. And he kind of wears these leaves. So that's a marketing strategy that doesn't work out. No, but everybody at the time says, oh, brilliant. Love it. Everyone's shouting bravo and people are kissing him and kissing each other. And they take kind of green ribbons or they take bits of branches or sort of leaves and stuff,
他们冲进剧院。这非常像“停止石油”运动之类的，不是吗？他们扰乱演出，说，现在有危机，这是一个哀悼的时刻。你知道，每个人都应该走上街头，哀悼内克的离开。
anything green. And then they go out into the streets of the capital, out of the Palais Royal into the streets of the capital. Some of them wearing kind of mourning clothes to mourn Nneka's dismissal.
他们入侵了一个蜡像馆。我的意思是，这太元了。太元了。是的。由一个叫菲利普·库尔修斯的人经营。现在，菲利普·库尔修斯，他是那个后来成为杜莎夫人的小女孩玛丽的赞助人。
They burst into theatres. It's very kind of just stop oil or something, isn't it? They disrupt performances and they say, there's a crisis on this is a moment of mourning. You know, everyone should go out in the streets and mourn the departure of NECA.
杜莎夫人。是的。蜡像馆。在蜡像馆里，菲利普·库尔修斯的蜡像馆。有很多头颅，不是吗？他们有奥尔良公爵的头颅和内克的头颅。人群抓住了这些头颅，他们在街上游行。我知道。
They invade a wax museum. I mean, this is so meta. So meta. Yeah. Run by a guy called Philippe Curtius. Now, Philippe Curtius, he is the patron of a little girl called Marie, who ends up becoming Madame Tussauds.
我的意思是，这令人难以置信。确实。这太离奇了。是的。所以整个故事是以头颅为首尾的。确实是这样。所以无论如何，人群在街上横冲直撞，大喊大叫，挥舞着头颅等等。
Madame Tussauds. Yeah. Wax museum. And in the wax museum, Philippe Curtis' wax museum. Lots of heads, aren't there? They've got a head of the Duke of Ornia and a head of Necker. And the crowd grab these heads and they're kind of parading around in the streets. I know.
他们到达了旺多姆广场。在旺多姆广场，一些部队在那里。他们是皇家德意志骑兵。他们是讲德语的部队。他们试图清理广场。基本上，这演变成了这些龙骑兵和人群之间的战斗。战斗从旺多姆广场蔓延到路易十五广场，也就是杜乐丽花园的尽头。那现在是协和广场。
I mean, it's unbelievable. It is. It's so bizarre. Yeah. So the whole story is bookended with heads. It is. It is indeed. So anyway, the crowd rampage through the streets, shouting and waving the heads and all this.
完全正确，汤姆，是的。这个位于巴黎市中心的巨大皇家游乐园。现在，花园里挤满了星期天散步的中产阶级巴黎人。妇女、儿童、家庭等等。战斗，现在已经变成了人群和龙骑兵之间的战斗，基本上蔓延到了公园里，蔓延到了所有这些人散步的地方。一片混乱。人群从咖啡馆露台上抓东西扔向士兵，椅子、石头、雕像碎片。
And they get to the Place Vendôme. And at the Place Vendôme, some of these troops are there. They're the Royal Allemands. They're German-speaking troops. And they try to clear the square. And basically, this degenerates into fighting between these dragoons and the crowd. And the fighting spills over from the Place Vendôme into the Place Louis-Cannes, which is at the end of the Tuileries Gardens. And that's the Place de la Concorde now.
因为当人们惊慌失措地逃跑时，消息传遍了全城。德国人和瑞士人疯了。他们在屠杀人民。就在那时，另一支军事分队，他们被称为法国卫队。所以法国卫队，他们到达现场试图保护人民免受德国和瑞士骑兵的伤害。现在，法国卫队是一支步兵部队，他们非常不同。他们是年轻人。他们通常来自北方的城镇，最近几周他们表现得极其不可靠。传单在法国卫队中流传。我们在成为士兵之前是公民。我们是
Exactly, Tom, yes. This great kind of royal pleasure park in the centre of Paris. Now, the gardens are filled with middle-class Parisians on a Sunday stroll. Women, children, families and whatnot. And the fighting, which it has now become between the crowd and the dragoons, basically spills right over into the park into where all these people are strolling. Total chaos. The crowd are grabbing things from kind of cafe terraces and throwing them at the soldiers, chairs, kind of stones, bits of statues.
法国人，在成为奴隶之前。换句话说，他们已经，可以说，被玷污了，这不是正确的词，但自由和美德的修辞已经渗透到他们身上，就像渗透到法国生活的许多其他方面一样。这就像2000年的警察下跪。是的，警察下跪，完全正确。所以，暴徒和法国卫队一起，实际上把骑兵赶出了杜乐丽花园。
And because as people are fleeing in panic, screaming and stuff, the word spreads around the city. The Germans and the Swiss have gone mad. They're massacring the people. And at that point, another military detachment, these are called the Garde Française. So the French guards, they arrive on the scene to try and protect the people from the German and Swiss troopers. Now, the Garde Française are an infantry unit, and they are very different. They are young men. They are often provincial from northern towns, and they have proved in recent weeks extremely unreliable. Pamphlets have been circulating among the French guards. We are citizens before we're soldiers. We are
就在那时，城里的皇家指挥官，名叫贝森瓦尔男爵，他向他所有的骑兵下达了命令，实际上是撤离整个城市，而不是战斗。他很害怕，这是对的。他说，我们不能信任我们自己的士兵来守住防线。他们正在崩溃并投向暴徒。所以在那一刻，城市对当局来说已经失去了。而这正是某种，好吧，没有其他说法，一场毁灭的狂欢的信号，汤姆。或者说推翻压迫和暴政的象征。一场解放的嘉年华。所以当皇家军队撤退到塞夫尔桥，一座向西的桥时，人群入侵了枪支店、军械库等等，他们强迫他们交出能找到的任何武器。
Frenchmen before we are slaves. In other words, they have been, as it were, I was going to say tainted, that's not the right word, but the rhetoric of liberty and virtue has permeated them as it has so many other aspects of French life. It's like the police taking the knee in 2000. Yeah, the police taking the knee, exactly. So together, the rioters and the garde français actually drive the cavalry troopers out of the Tuileries Gardens.
到目前为止，他们中的许多人也用匕首和棍棒，甚至厨房刀具武装了自己。他们前往城市的北部，那里有一堵巨大的墙，一个海关屏障。因为记住，我们在上一集中说过，法国此时有很多内部关税、内部经济壁垒、保护主义壁垒，以及字面意义上的海关屏障。这是最著名的一个。它是由拉瓦锡建造的，他是法国最伟大的化学家。
And at that point, the royal commander in the city, who is called Baron de Bessenval, he gives the order to all his troopers to evacuate effectively the whole of the city rather than fight. And he's frightened, rightly. He says, we cannot trust our own soldiers to hold the line. They are breaking and defecting to the rioters. So in that moment, the city is lost to the authorities. And that then is the cue for a kind of, well, there's no other way of putting it, an orgy of destruction, Tom. Or a toppling of symbols of oppression and tyranny. A carnival of liberation. So as the royal troops withdraw to the Pont de Sèvres, a bridge to the west, the crowd invades gun shops, armourers, and so on, and they force them to hand over whatever weapons they can find.
他这样做是因为他投资了这种包税公司。因此，有了这道墙，他们可以监管进出城市的货物。他这样做，显然是为了筹集资金。这在适当的时候看起来不会很好，拉瓦锡最终会被送上断头台。但我总是喜欢这个故事。
They've also, many of them by now, armed themselves with daggers and clubs, even kitchen knives. And they head to the north of the city, where there is this great wall, a customs barrier. Because remember, we said in a previous episode, France at this point has a lot of internal duties, internal economic barriers, protectionist barriers, and literally customs barriers. And this is the most famous one. And it's built by Lavoisier, who is the greatest chemist in France.
我实际上做过一个关于拉瓦锡的学校项目。哦，不会吧。是的。所以他一直在我心中占据着重要的位置，因为虽然他无疑是这种剥削框架的一部分，但他当然也是一位杰出的化学家。我的意思是，他基本上反驳了那种所谓的燃素的奇怪元素，那种导致爆炸之类的东西。他说，不，这完全是关于氧气之类的。
And he has done it because he has invested in this kind of tax farming company. So therefore, with this war, they can regulate the goods that come in and out of the city. And he's doing that, obviously, to raise money. And this will not look good in due course, and Lavoisier will end up guillotined. But I always love this story.
我在这里稍微转述一下。化学家们也许能够完善这种看法。但同时，他正在将他赚到的大部分钱投资于慈善事业。其中之一是监狱改革。他非常、非常热衷于改善囚犯的条件。另一个，考虑到这正值奥运会期间，非常应景的是，他非常热衷于净化塞纳河的水。所以这是一种旧制度的奇怪结合，它既是剥削性的，又是压迫性的，既是开明的，又是富有同情心的，所有这些都在一个令人困惑的镜厅里。历史很复杂，汤姆。
I actually did a school project on Lavoisier. Oh, no way. Yeah. So he's always been close to my heart because although he's undoubtedly part of this kind of exploitative framework, he is also, of course, a brilliant chemist. I mean, he basically disproves that there's this kind of weird element supposedly called phlogiston that kind of results in explosions and things. And he says, no, it's all about oxygen and stuff.
确实很复杂。人很复杂，不是吗？是的。这很复杂。所以，我的意思是，他的墙是一件了不起的东西。它周长18英里，高10英尺。你知道，这真的。如果它今天还立着，你会去参观它，它会是一个旅游景点。无论如何，它没有立着，因为
I'm slightly paraphrasing here. Chemists may be able to refine that take on it. But also, he is investing a lot of the money that he is making in charitable causes. Among those is prison reform. He's very, very keen on improving conditions for prisoners. And the other, rather topically, bearing in mind that this is going out in the fortnight of the Olympics, he's very keen on purifying the water in the Seine. So it's kind of weird nexus of the Ancien Régime, that it's exploitative, it's oppressive, it's enlightened, and it's compassionate, all in one kind of confusing hall of mirrors. History is complicated, Tom.
人群拆毁了墙，他们拆毁了墙周围的40个海关哨所，他们烧毁了海关哨所的所有记录。现在，烧毁记录，人们在乡下同时也这样做。他们闯入城堡之类的。这非常像农民起义。完全正确。烧毁封建记录。作为他们自己从属地位的证据。所以这就是人们在巴黎城外所做的事情。他们整晚都在这样做。现在，回到城内，当然，有很多失去很多的人。有拥有财产的中产阶级，基本上是到目前为止一直指导
It is complicated. People are complicated, aren't they? Yeah. It is complicated. So, I mean, his wall is an amazing thing. It's 18 miles in circumference and 10 feet high. You know, it's a really. If it was standing today, you'd go and see it as it would be a tourist attraction. Anyway, it's not standing because
革命进程的人。他们中的许多人非常担心军队已经撤离城市，法律和秩序完全崩溃。有一群王室官员聚集在一个实际上是市长的人周围。他被称为商人教长。他的名字叫雅克·德·弗莱塞尔。我们将在本集结束时回到他身边。剧透警告，他的结局不太好。市长基本上说，听着，我们需要团结
the crowd demolished the wall and they demolished 40 customs posts, which are intervals around the wall, and they burn all the records from the customs post. Now, burning the records, people are doing this in the countryside at the same time. They're breaking into castles and things. It's very like the Peasants' Revolt. Exactly. Burning the feudal records. The evidence, as it were, of their own subordinate status. So this is what people are doing outside Paris. And they're doing this all night. Now, back inside the city, of course, there are a lot of people with a lot to lose. There are the propertied middle classes, basically the people who up till now have been directing the
秩序的力量。我们将在7月13日黎明时分这样做。我们将敲响警钟，教堂，钟声会敲响，一个紧急信号，我们将发射大炮，会有鼓声，这些将召集选区的代表到市政厅，我们将开会，我们将决定做什么。据推测，这对其他人会有非常平静的影响。这是他们所希望的，是的，疯狂。因为一旦警钟在黎明开始敲响，人们就会想，发生了什么事？每个人都涌上街头，以为城市受到了军队的攻击，或者谁知道是什么。现在，在市政厅，选区的代表们到达了，他们同意组成一个公社，
revolutionary process. And a lot of them are extremely worried about the fact that the army has vacated the city and law and order is completely breaking down. And there's a group of royal officials that huddle around a guy who's effectively the mayor. He's called the provost of merchants, the Prévost de Marchand. His name is Jacques de Flessel. And we will come back to him at the end of this episode. Spoiler alert, he does not come to a very happy end. And the mayor basically says, listen, we need to kind of rally the forces of
一种非正式的城市行政机构来管理他们自己的事务。公社将成为法国大革命中伟大的权力基础之一，尽管当时当然没有人知道这一点。他们还说，现在有暴徒在街上游荡。还有治安维持会也在街上游荡。我们应该用民兵来规范所有这些。他们有趣地称之为资产阶级卫队。这就是最终成为国民卫队的东西，同样是革命故事中的关键角色。当然，他们一直戴着
order. And we will do this at dawn on the 13th of July. We'll sound the tocsin, the churches, the bells will toll, an emergency signal, we'll fire cannons, there will be drums, and these will call out representatives from the electoral districts to the Hôtel de Ville, the city hall, and we will meet and we will decide what to do. And presumably this will have a very calming effect on everyone else. This is what they're hoping, yeah, madness. Because as soon as the toxin starts tolling at dawn, people are like, what's going on? And everyone pours out into the streets thinking the city's under attack from the army or who knows what. Now, at the Eau de la Ville, the representatives of the electoral districts arrive and they agree to form a commune,
卡米尔·德穆兰的绿色小枝。绿色小枝，完全正确。他们说，好吧，这绿色生意是垃圾，尤其是因为绿色是伟大的反动派之一，国王的兄弟，阿图瓦伯爵的象征。他们说，我们不能戴他的颜色。为什么我们不戴巴黎的颜色，红色和蓝色？所以那天早上，他们把帽徽换成了红色和蓝色的帽徽。我们稍后会讨论帽徽的象征意义。所以与此同时，街头的无政府状态实际上正在恶化。那天早上，暴徒洗劫了圣拉扎尔修道院。也就是博马舍被囚禁的地方。
a sort of an informal city administration to run their own affairs. The commune will become one of the great power bases in the French Revolution, although nobody, of course, knows this at the time. And they also say there are now mobs roaming the streets. There are also bands of vigilantes roaming the streets. We should regularize all this with a militia. They call it, entertainingly, the garde bourgeoise, the bourgeois guard. And this is what becomes, ultimately, the National Guard, again, a key player in the revolutionary story. And they've been wearing, of course,
对，完全正确。对你关于费加罗的婚礼的事情的一个很好的致敬，汤姆。完全正确。他们在那里发现了很多食物、葡萄酒、醋、25块格鲁耶尔奶酪，这正是我坦率地期望在修道院里找到的东西，还有一个巨大的干羊头，我的意思是，谁知道你会用那个做什么，那是汤的基础吗？谁知道，好吧，我不知道，我的意思是，所以修道院和女修道院总是色情幻想的背景。它们是。旧制度。
Camille Desmoulins' green sprigs. Green sprigs, exactly. And they say, well, this green business is rubbish, not least because green is the symbol of one of the great reactionaries, the king's brother, the Comte d'Artois. And they said, we can't be wearing his color. Why don't we wear the colors of Paris, red and blue? So that morning, they swapped their cockades for red and blue cockades. We will discuss the symbolism of cockades a little bit later. So meanwhile, the anarchy on the streets is actually getting worse. That morning, rioters sacked the convent of Saint-Lazare. Which is where Beaumarchais had been imprisoned.
所以谁知道那里发生了什么？关于奶酪。是的。所以无论如何，他们拿走了所有这些东西，他们说，哦，好吧，这绝对证明了。特权阶级，僧侣，牧师，大人物一直都在囤积食物。而这当然只会让他们更加愤怒。现在，他们迫切需要武器，因为他们认为自己会受到攻击。他们洗劫了一个皇家仓库。他们得到了大量的长戟。
Right, exactly. A nice nod back to your thing about the marriage of Figaro, Tom. Exactly. They find there a lot of food, wine vinegar 25 gruyere cheeses which is exactly what i'd expect to be in a monastery frankly and a large dried ram's head i mean who knows what you'd be doing with that is that the basis for a soup who knows well i don't know i mean so monasteries and convents are always the setting for pornographic fantasies. They are. The Orsiar regime.
我们在英国选举那一集中有几个长戟，所以很高兴长戟回到节目中。太棒了。弩。他们有一门路易十四时期暹罗国王赠送的大炮。多么细节。一门银衬大炮。它基本上是一个玩具，一个玩具大炮，真人大小的玩具大炮。
So who knows what's going on there? About cheese. Yes. So anyway, they take all this stuff and they say, oh, well, this absolutely proves. The privileged classes, the monks, the priests, the bigwigs have been hoarding food all this time. And that, of course, only inflames them more. Now, they're desperate to get weapons because they think they're going to come under attack. They ransack a royal storehouse. They get loads of halberds.
无论如何，他们有这门大炮。我喜欢认为装饰着大象，你觉得呢？是的，几乎可以肯定。他们去了伟大的军事医院，荣军院。当我说是医院时，这是一个老兵退休的地方。所以那是拿破仑最终被埋葬的地方。我在那里拍过电影，多米尼克。你拍过吗？
We had a few halberds in our British elections episode, so it's great to have halberds back on the show. Brilliant. Crossbows. They've got a cannon that was given by the King of Siam to Louis XIV. What a detail. A silver-lined cannon. It was basically a toy, a toy cannon, life-size toy cannon.
我从来没去过荣军院，汤姆。我真的应该去向拿破仑致敬。我曾站在他的墓旁，被拍摄沉思。你当时在吗？我从来没去过荣军院，汤姆。我真的应该去向拿破仑致敬。我曾站在他的墓旁，被拍摄沉思。你当时在吗？是的。你当时在梦想入侵俄罗斯，把你的部队留在后面，就像你在入侵埃及后把他们留在后面一样吗？诅咒英国对海洋的控制。
Anyway, they've got this cannon. I like to think decorated with elephants, do you think? Yeah, almost certainly. They go to the great sort of military hospital, Les Invalides. When I say hospital, it's a place where old soldiers went to retire. So that's where Napoleon ends up buried. I have filmed there, Dominic. Have you?
完全正确。诅咒这个国家的店主。但显然在这一点上，他不在那里。这不言而喻。不，荣军院设法暂时把他们挡在了外面。与此同时，那个家伙，市长，弗莱塞尔，正在玩一种看起来非常奇怪的游戏。人们对他说，武器在哪里？他把他们打发到城市的不同地方，看起来那里显然不会有任何武器。人们开始怀疑，心想，他在玩双重游戏吗？他只是想通过让我们进行一些徒劳的追逐来争取时间吗？
I've never been to Les Invalides, Tom. I really should go and pay my respects to Napoleon. I have stood next to his tomb and been filmed pondering. Were you? I've never been to the Anvilide, Tom. I really should go and pay my respects to Napoleon. I have stood next to his tomb and been filmed pondering. Were you? Yes. Were you dreaming about invading Russia, leaving your troops behind as you'd left them behind after invading Egypt? Cursing the British mastery of the sea.
但整整一天，13日，有一种日益混乱的感觉。然后第二天，14日星期二，黎明破晓，面包价格，考虑到混乱，不出所料，现在已经达到了历史最高点。所以现在大约是15苏。去市场买面包的妇女非常愤怒，说，你知道，这是不可容忍的。我们不能吃。我们必须自己动手。所以那天早上，人群比以往任何时候都多。大约8万人回到荣军院。他们闯入。场面极其混乱，发生了踩踏。有挤压。人们被踩在脚下。他们得到了火枪，大约5000支火枪。他们拿出了大约20门大炮，并在人群中分发。但有一件事他们
Exactly. Cursing the nation's shopkeepers. But obviously at this point, he's not there. That goes without saying. No, the Anvilide managed to sort of keep them away for the time being. Meanwhile, that guy, the mayor, Flessel, is sort of playing what seems to be a very strange game. People are saying to him, where are the arms? And he's sending them off to different parts of the city where it seems like there's obviously not going to be any weapons. And people are starting to be suspicious and thinking, is he playing a double game? Is he just trying to buy time by sending us some wild goose chases?
没有。他们没有任何火药。他们基本上没有任何东西可以让大炮工作。所以多米尼克，巴黎有没有什么地方可能有现成的火药供应？有一个地方，汤姆。那个地方就是巴士底狱，巴黎市中心的巨大堡垒。现在人群把注意力转向了巴士底狱。汤姆，兴奋程度已经达到了如此高的程度，我想我们是否应该为了我们自己的健康和安全原因休息一下。我想我们应该。否则我无法应对压力。我们几分钟后回来，继续巴士底狱的攻占。我是玛丽娜·海德。
But all that day, the 13th, there is a sense of kind of increasing disorder. And then dawn breaks the following day, Tuesday, the 14th, and the bread price, not surprisingly given the chaos, has now reached its all-time peak. So it's now about 15 soup. And women who are going out to the markets to get bread are incredibly angry and saying, you know, this is intolerable. We can't eat. We must take matters into our own hands. So that morning, the crowds are bigger than ever. About 80,000 people return to the Zanvylid. They break in. Scenes of tremendous chaos kind of stampede. There's a crush. People have been crushed underfoot. They get muskets, about 5,000 muskets. They take out about 20 cannons and they're passing them out among the crowd. But there is one thing they
我是理查德·奥斯曼。我们一起主持《娱乐余味》。这是你每周的娱乐新闻、评论、一点演艺圈八卦，在我们的问答环节，我们揭开娱乐的幕布，告诉你这一切是如何运作的。我们刚刚推出了我们的会员俱乐部。如果你想要无广告收听、额外剧集，
don't have. They don't have any gunpowder. They don't have anything to basically make the cannons work. And so Dominic, is there anywhere in Paris that might have a ready supply of gunpowder? There is one place, Tom. And that place is the Bastille, the great fortress in the centre of Paris. And now the crowd turn their attention to the Bastille. And Tom, the excitement has reached such a pitch that I wonder if we should take a break just for our own health and safety reasons. I think we should. I can't cope with the stress otherwise. We'll be back in a few minutes with the storming of the Bastille. I'm Marina Hyde.
以及抢先获得现场门票，请前往 therestisentertainment.com。那是 therestisentertainment.com。你好，欢迎回到《历史余味》，多米尼克，我们正在接近法国历史上、全球历史上最著名的时刻之一。是的，巴士底狱，开始吧。所以巴士底狱，汤姆，你会知道，因为你做过一期关于铁面人的精彩节目，巴士底狱并不完全是我们认为的那样。在我们的想象中，巴士底狱是这座高耸的哥特式城堡，嗯，画作中就是这样展示的，不是吗？在画作中，它笼罩着城市，它是王室压迫的可怕象征，是专制和暴政的化身等等。嗯，它
And I'm Richard Osman. And together we host The Rest Is Entertainment. It's your weekly fix of entertainment news, reviews, a splash of showbiz gossip, and on our Q&A, we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works. We have just launched our Members Club. If you want ad-free listening, bonus episodes,
也是哥特式的，因为这是哥特式小说的时期。是的，它也是哥特式的，不是吗？因为这是哥特式小说的时期。是的。它是阿尔卑斯山中一座阴森的男爵府邸的移植，直接移植到了巴黎市中心。但那实际上并不是它。完全正确。我想它有一点伦敦塔的特质。但它相当矮胖。它有八座圆塔，墙壁有五英尺厚。但它是在百年战争中建造的
and early access to live tickets, head to therestisentertainment.com. That's therestisentertainment.com. Hello, welcome back to the rest is history and dominic we are approaching one of the most celebrated moments in french history in global history yeah the bastille take it away so the bastille tom you will know because you did a wonderful episode about the man in the iron mask that the bastille is not quite what we think it was so in our imagination the Bastille is this towering gothic castle well that's how it's shown in the paintings isn't it in the paintings it's looming over the city it's this terrible symbol of royal oppression the embodiment of despotism and tyranny and whatnot well it's
作为防御英国人的堡垒，我很自豪地说。疯子查理，查理六世，把它改建成了一座监狱。嗯，我们将在几周后我们要做的关于亨利五世的系列节目中探讨这一点。百年战争？完全正确。但正是17世纪的黎塞留红衣主教真正说，让我们把它用作国家囚犯的监狱。正如你在关于铁面人的节目中所描述的那样，有一种东西叫密令。这是一种由国王批准的密封信，其中你的罪行通常没有真正命名。但基本上，如果有密令，你可以在没有任何程序、没有任何审判的情况下被判刑。你可以基本上被扔进监狱。
gothic isn't it as well because this is the kind of the period of gothic fiction yes, it's Gothic, isn't it, as well? Because this is the kind of the period of Gothic fiction. Yes. And it's a transplantation of a sinister baronial pile in the Alps or something right into the middle of Paris. But that's not actually what it is. Exactly. It's got a bit of a Tower of London quality to it, I suppose. But it's quite squat. It has eight round towers and it has walls that are five feet thick. But it had been built in the Hundred Years
这难道不也是哥特式的吗？因为这正是哥特小说的时期。是的。它就像是从阿尔卑斯山或其他什么地方，把一座阴森的男爵城堡移植到了巴黎市中心。但实际上它并非如此。没错。我想它带有一点伦敦塔的特质。但它相当矮胖。它有八座圆塔，墙壁有五英尺厚。但它是在百年战争期间建造的
War as a defence against the English, I'm proud to say. And Charles the Mad, Charles VI, had converted it into a prison. Well, we'll be looking at this in a series we're going to be doing on Henry V in a few weeks' time. The Hundred Years War? Exactly. But it was Cardinal Richelieu in the 17th century who really said, let's use it as a prison for prisoners of state. And the people who were sent there, as you described in your episode that you did on the man in the iron mask, there's a thing called a lettre de cachet. And this is a kind of sealed letter approved by the king in which your crime is often not really named. But basically, if there's a lettre de cachet, you can be sentenced without any process, without any trial. You can be basically thrown behind bars.
作为防御英国人的工事，我很自豪地说。疯子查理，也就是查理六世，曾把它改建成了一座监狱。嗯，我们将在几周后关于亨利五世的系列节目中探讨这个问题。百年战争？没错。但正是17世纪的黎塞留枢机主教真正提出，让我们把它用作关押国家囚犯的监狱。正如你在关于铁面人那一集中所描述的那样，被送到那里的人，有一种东西叫“密令”（lettre de cachet）。这是一种由国王批准的密封信件，信中通常并没有真正说明你的罪行。但基本上，只要有“密令”，你就可以在没有任何程序、没有任何审判的情况下被判刑。你基本上可以直接被关进大牢。
So people are obviously up in arms. They see this as a symbol of arbitrary government and despotism and absolutism and whatnot. But there are kind of three kinds really, aren't there? Yeah. So there's people who are seen as engaged in conspiracy against the monarchy. Yes. Of whom, whoever he is, the man in the iron mask, would be the exemplary example. And there are writers whose works are seen to be seditious. So the most famous of these writers
人们显然非常愤怒。他们将此视为专制政府、暴政和绝对主义等的象征。但实际上有三种人，不是吗？是的。一种是被视为参与了反君主制阴谋的人。是的。无论他是谁，铁面人就是其中的典型代表。还有一些作家的作品被视为煽动性的。所以这些作家中最著名的是
is Voltaire, the great kind of wit and philosoph who actually writes the story of the man in the iron mask and kind of invents it as a symbol of royal tyranny. And then there are people who are seen by their own families as trouble. And again, there is a famous archetype of this, a literary figure who we've also done an episode on, and that is the Marquis de Sade. That's right. So delinquents, aristocratic usually, whose own families basically petition the monarchy, please can you have my son locked up? He's totally out of control. I mean, that's what it is, isn't it? And actually it's quite a kind of mark of status, isn't it? If you're a writer or a rebel. To be sent to the Bastille.
伏尔泰，那位伟大的机智之士和哲学家，他实际上写了铁面人的故事，并将其塑造为皇权暴政的象征。还有一些被家人视为麻烦的人。同样，这也有一个著名的原型，一个我们做过一期节目的文学人物，那就是萨德侯爵。没错。所以那些通常是贵族出身的违纪者，他们的家人基本上会向君主请愿，请求把我的儿子关起来，他完全失控了。我的意思是，事实就是这样，不是吗？而且，如果你是一个作家或反叛者，被送进巴士底狱，这实际上是一种地位的象征，不是吗？
Yeah. To be sent there, because that's what Beaumarchais finds so humiliating when he's sent to Saint-Lazare, that he isn't sent to the Bastille. Yeah. And actually, Conditions in the Bastille, when I read up on it, it reminded me of the prisons that Dickens describes, like the Marshall Sea or something. So it's all a bit Dickensian. Sharma compares it to an overgrown lodging house with guests living in different rooms according to their station.
是的。被送进去，因为博马舍被送往圣拉扎尔监狱时感到非常羞辱，就是因为他没被送进巴士底狱。是的。事实上，当我查阅巴士底狱的条件时，它让我想起了狄更斯描述的监狱，比如马夏尔西监狱之类的。所以这一切都有点狄更斯风格。夏尔马将其比作一个杂乱的寄宿公寓，客人们根据自己的身份住在不同的房间里。
If you're a member of the public, you can actually walk into the Bastille. You can go in and sort of, there are shops on the inside. There's a garden. The governor has a vegetable garden. So you can have a stroll and stuff. And inside, further inside,
如果你是普通公众，你实际上可以走进巴士底狱。你可以进去，里面有商店。还有一个花园。总督有一个菜园。所以你可以进去散散步之类的。而在里面，更深处，
there's the kind of warren of rooms where the inmates are kept. And the conditions are actually not really that bad. So the extraordinary thing is you are better off inside the Bastille than the vast majority of French people who live outside it. Well, the Marquis de Sade lives quite well. I mean, he's able to write his novel. Yeah. You have alcohol.
有一片像迷宫一样的房间，囚犯们被关在那里。条件其实并没有那么糟糕。所以最不可思议的是，在巴士底狱里比绝大多数住在外面的法国人过得还要好。嗯，萨德侯爵住得相当不错。我的意思是，他能写他的小说。是的。你有酒喝。
He sends his wife out to get him cheese and all kinds of things. That's right. He has 133 books when he's in there. And he has a desk and he has dressing gowns. He has aftershave. He's allowed all these kind of treats. This is the norm. There are card games.
他派他的妻子出去为他买奶酪和各种各样的东西。没错。他在那里时有133本书。他有一张书桌，还有睡袍。他有须后水。他被允许享受所有这些款待。这是常态。还有纸牌游戏。
There's a billiard table. There's a writer called Jean-François Marmantel. He was asked what was the food like in the Bastille and he said, I always remember an excellent soup, a succulent side of beef, a thigh of boiled chicken oozing with grease, a little dish of fried marinated artichokes, really some fine croissant prayers, a bottle of old Burgundy, the very best mocha coffee. So it's more like a hotel than a prison. And the demonology of it was invented by
有一张台球桌。有一位作家叫让-弗朗索瓦·马蒙泰尔。有人问他巴士底狱的食物怎么样，他说，我总是记得那美味的汤，多汁的牛排，滴着油脂的煮鸡腿，一小盘油炸腌洋蓟，还有非常好的羊角面包，一瓶陈年勃艮第红酒，最好的摩卡咖啡。所以它更像是一家酒店而不是监狱。而它的妖魔化是由
writers to criticize the regime. So Voltaire? Yes. The most famous is a guy actually called Linge, who was a barrister who was sent there, and we don't really know why, in 1780. And he published a book called Memoirs of the Bastille. And this is your classic kind of Gothic nightmare. You know, clanking chains, the door crashing shut behind you. And he invented the idea, really, that the Bastille was this kind of living tomb, that everybody in it was the walking dead. They would never be heard from again. Well, he must be drawing on the Voltaire, the idea of the Man in the Iron Mask as well. Those ideas have quite deep roots. They do. And they're actually so successful,
作家们为了批评政权而编造出来的。伏尔泰吗？是的。最著名的是一个叫林格的人，他是一名律师，1780年被送进去，我们其实不知道原因。他出版了一本名为《巴士底狱回忆录》的书。这就是你那种经典的哥特式噩梦。你知道，叮当作响的锁链，在你身后砰然关上的门。他确实创造了这样一种观念：巴士底狱是一个活生生的坟墓，里面的人都是行尸走肉。他们永远不会再有消息。嗯，他一定也借鉴了伏尔泰关于铁面人的想法。这些想法根深蒂固。确实。而且它们实际上非常成功，
those ideas, that the government themselves have decided the Bastille has to go. Because even though it's fine, it's kind of bad publicity to have it. So by the 1780s, they have a plan to redevelop the Bastille. They're going to build a park instead with a column and fountains in the middle. And there'll be an inscription that says, ironically, Louis XVI, restorer of public freedom. Of course, that park, that never happens. I mean, the shades of irony that veil the totemic episodes in the French Revolution are amazing. So the Bastille has featured in people's imagination in the days leading up to the 14th of July, partly because of the Marquis de Sade, actually.
这些想法，以至于政府自己也决定巴士底狱必须拆除。因为尽管它没什么问题，但拥有它是一种糟糕的宣传。所以到了18世纪80年代，他们有了一个重建巴士底狱的计划。他们打算建一个公园，中间有一根柱子和喷泉。还会有一个讽刺性的铭文，写着“路易十六，公共自由的恢复者”。当然，那个公园从未建成。我的意思是，笼罩在法国大革命标志性事件上的讽刺意味真是令人惊叹。所以巴士底狱在7月14日之前的日子里一直出现在人们的想象中，实际上部分归功于萨德侯爵。
So he's in the Bastille. He's been following all the news from Versailles. He's really into it, isn't he? And he's been shouting political harangues from the window. Yes, because he takes the thing that he pees into, kind of metal. A funnel. And he uses that to shout out revolutionary slogans. Exactly.
所以他当时在巴士底狱。他一直在关注凡尔赛宫的所有新闻。他真的很投入，不是吗？他一直在窗边大声发表政治演说。是的，因为他拿了一个他用来小便的东西，某种金属制品。一个漏斗。他用那个来高喊革命口号。没错。
And he says, I'm in here with hundreds of inmates and the governor is planning to kill us all. And this is a complete fantasy. So he gets bundled off to a lunatic asylum, Charenton. A lunatic asylum. He's got to go. He's a real pain. Now, actually, we've mentioned the governor. So the Marquis de Sables kicked out nine days ago.
他说，我和数百名囚犯关在这里，总督正计划杀死我们所有人。这完全是幻想。所以他被强行送往精神病院，沙朗通。精神病院。他必须走。他真是个麻烦。现在，实际上，我们提到了总督。所以萨德侯爵在九天前被赶走了。
And the governor in those nine days has been getting increasingly worried, as you might expect. His name is Bernard-José de Launay, and he is 49 years old. He was born in the Bastille. His father had been the governor as well. And basically, he's a very, very dutiful, humdrum, uncontroversial civil servant, the guy who runs the Bastille. He's not a bad man. He's not a bad man. He's not a torturer. He's nothing like that. He's just kind of a boring official. He doesn't cackle evilly while fettering people in dripping dungeons.
而总督在这九天里变得越来越担心，正如你所料。他的名字叫伯纳德-何塞·德·洛奈，他今年49岁。他出生在巴士底狱。他的父亲也曾是总督。基本上，他是一个非常非常尽职、平庸、毫无争议的公务员，负责管理巴士底狱。他不是个坏人。他不是个坏人。他不是个折磨者。他根本不是那样的人。他只是一个无聊的官员。他不会在把人锁在滴水的地牢里时发出邪恶的笑声。
Not at all. And he's been given this gunpowder to guard. The gunpowder has been sent to him, 250 barrels of it. And he's been told, you know, don't let anyone have it. He has been sort of making vague preparations, like moving the cannons to the embrasures. He's told his men to gather some stones to throw at people if they try to get in, and bits of iron, mungery and stuff.
一点也不。他被派去守卫这些火药。火药被送到了他那里，一共250桶。他被告知，你知道，不要让任何人拿到它。他一直在做一些模糊的准备，比如把大炮移到射击孔。他告诉他的人收集一些石头，如果有人试图闯入就扔向他们，还有一些铁器之类的东西。
And I say his men. He has 82 old soldiers, pensioners, avalides as they're called, and they are just loafers. They're completely useless. They're not going to be at all used in a fight. And he's also been sent 32 Swiss guards. He has enough food to last him two days and he has no water supply whatsoever. So when he sees this giant crowd advancing towards him, he thinks, oh, for God's sake, this is the last thing I need. Now, this crowd later ends up being sort of, dare I say, sacralized, Tom. There are 954 of them, and they are aged
我说他的人。他有82名老兵，养老金领取者，也就是所谓的“残疾军人”，他们只是游手好闲的人。他们完全没用。他们在战斗中根本派不上用场。他还被派了32名瑞士卫兵。他的食物只够维持两天，而且他没有任何供水。所以当他看到这群庞大的人群向他涌来时，他想，哦，天哪，这真是最糟糕的情况。现在，这群人后来变得，我敢说，神圣化了，汤姆。他们有954人，年龄在
between 8 and 72, and they're known officially as the Vanqueurs. So most of these Vanqueurs are artisans from the Saint-Antoine neighborhood, the neighborhood around the Bastille. And they are joiners and glaziers and cabinet makers and locksmiths. So because they ended up as these great heroes of the revolution, we know loads about them. Only one of them is a woman, a laundress, or Marie Charpentier. Most of them, historians have really done tremendous work kind of analyzing their background. Most of them had not been born in Paris. So that gives you a sense of just how transient the Parisian population is. How many migrants have come from the countryside for work
8岁到72岁之间，官方称他们为“征服者”。所以这些“征服者”大多是来自圣安托万区的工匠，也就是巴士底狱周围的街区。他们是细木工、玻璃工、橱柜工和锁匠。因为他们最终成为了革命的伟大英雄，我们对他们了解很多。其中只有一名女性，一名洗衣女工，玛丽·夏尔庞捷。大多数人，历史学家确实做了大量工作来分析他们的背景。他们大多数不是在巴黎出生的。这让你感觉到巴黎的人口流动性有多大。有多少移民从农村来到这里工作
or for bread and are now angry and resentful. Because in a city like Paris, people are going to die of disease. And so the population cannot be maintained without this constant influx of people. Constant flow. Yes, exactly. So they are angry, resentful, hungry. They're also frightened. There are lots of rumors that they army out preparing to retake the city. They're desperate to get this gunpowder. So they've assembled, a thousand of them or so,
或者为了面包，现在感到愤怒和怨恨。因为在像巴黎这样的城市，人们会死于疾病。所以如果没有这种持续的人口流入，人口就无法维持。持续的流动。是的，没错。所以他们愤怒、怨恨、饥饿。他们也很害怕。有很多传言说军队正在准备夺回城市。他们迫切想要得到这些火药。所以他们聚集了大约一千人，
shouting and roaring outside the walls of the Bastille. More happily for Delaunay, two delegates arrive from the city hall, from the Hôtel de Ville, and they say, look, we've come to see you. And he says, well, funnily enough, I'm about to have dinner. It's 10 o'clock. So it's described as his déjeuner, but it's more of a brunch.
在巴士底狱的围墙外大喊大叫。对德洛奈来说更幸运的是，两名代表从市政厅，也就是巴黎市政厅赶来，他们说，看，我们来看你了。他说，嗯，真巧，我正要吃晚饭。现在是10点钟。所以这被描述为他的午餐，但更像是一顿早午餐。
He's about to have brunch. Petit déjeuner. And he says, why don't you come in? So these guys go in and they have this enormous, I mean, obviously it's France, right? They have this enormous meal, which goes on for hours. And the crowd become very restless. Well, if they're all starving to death outside. Right.
他正要吃早午餐。小午餐。他说，你们为什么不进来呢？所以这些人进去了，他们吃了这顿丰盛的，我的意思是，显然这是法国，对吧？他们吃了这顿丰盛的饭，持续了好几个小时。人群变得非常焦躁不安。嗯，如果他们在外面都快饿死了。对。
And they're all having their croissant. And of course, we know what they're eating in the Bastille. They're having an excellent soup, a second inside of beef, a thigh of boiled chicken, oozing with grease. They're having all this. Brilliant. Yeah. The crowd get very restless.
他们都在吃他们的羊角面包。当然，我们知道他们在巴士底狱吃什么。他们吃着美味的汤，第二份牛排，煮鸡腿，滴着油脂。他们吃着所有这些。太棒了。是的。人群变得非常焦躁不安。
Another deputy arrives, and he goes in to see Delon. And by this time, he's got a very firm list of demands he says we want all your guns as cannons as well as the gunpowder and you must allow our new militia the bourgeois guard to take over the Bastille and Delaunay says look I can't do that I need instructions from Versailles I've got my orders I'm just doing my job I don't want any trouble but you can't ask me stuff that I can't deliver. Thurio says, you know, I understand where you're coming from. I'm not happy about it,
另一名代表到了，他进去见德洛奈。到这个时候，他有一份非常明确的要求清单，他说我们想要你所有的枪，包括大炮和火药，你必须允许我们的新民兵，资产阶级卫队接管巴士底狱。德洛奈说，看，我做不到，我需要凡尔赛的指示，我有我的命令，我只是在做我的工作，我不想惹麻烦，但你不能要求我做我无法交付的事情。图里奥说，你知道，我理解你的处境。我不高兴，
but I will go back to the Hotel de Ville and report back and find out what's going to happen. So Thurio goes back to the Hotel de Ville and there all these sort of electors and officials huddle together and they're chatting for about an hour about what are we going to do about the Bastille? And actually their attitude is we don't want to fray in the centre of Paris.
但我会回到市政厅报告，看看会发生什么。所以图里奥回到市政厅，那里所有的选举人和官员聚在一起，他们聊了一个小时关于我们要怎么处理巴士底狱？事实上他们的态度是，我们不想在巴黎市中心发生冲突。
And Dominic, just to be clear, at this point, their concern is with the Bastille as a source of ammunition rather than its role as an emblem of royal tyranny. Yes, that is what they want. They want the gunpowder. They want the guns. But they're not talking about, you know, the Bastille as the Gothic castle and stuff. I mean, they can see the Bastille. They know what it is. But they've been talking for about an hour.
多米尼克，明确一下，此时，他们关心的是巴士底狱作为弹药来源，而不是它作为皇权暴政象征的角色。是的，这就是他们想要的。他们想要火药。他们想要枪。但他们并没有谈论，你知道，作为哥特式城堡之类的巴士底狱。我的意思是，他们能看到巴士底狱。他们知道它是什么。但他们已经谈了一个小时了。
It's 1.30. Turio is going to be sent back to the Bastille with a loud hailer to kind of address the crowd and stuff. When suddenly they hear there's this enormous explosion and the Hotel de Ville literally shakes. And then they hear this further explosions, gunfire, and it's all coming from the direction of the Bastille. What has happened? Well, while Turio and it's all coming from the direction of the Bastille. What has happened?
现在是1点半。图里奥要被派回巴士底狱，带着扩音器向人群喊话之类的。突然他们听到一声巨大的爆炸声，市政厅真的震动了。然后他们听到进一步的爆炸声、枪声，这一切都来自巴士底狱的方向。发生了什么？好吧，当图里奥和这一切都来自巴士底狱的方向。发生了什么？
Well, while Thurio and his friends have been meeting in the city hall, the crowd outside the Bastille have run out of patience and have just decided to take matters into their own hands. And some of them have started to burst into that outer courtyard with the vegetable garden and the shops shouting, give us the Bastille, give us the bastille give us the bastille a load of them climb up to the top of a perfume shop which is next to the gate that goes into the inner courtyard and there's a draw bridge which is closed they cut the ropes holding the drawbridge up now this is that classic kind of mad crowd behavior the drawbridge at this point falls open very unexpected and it crushes people underneath one person has died the rest of the crowd they're damn about that and they just run over the drawbridge presumably further flattening this poor man there are soldiers up at the top who are shouting stay away stay away we don't want to shoot you the crowd think they are saying come in come in we won't shoot so they
好吧，当图里奥和他的朋友们在市政厅开会时，巴士底狱外的人群已经失去了耐心，决定自己动手。他们中的一些人开始冲进那个有菜园和商店的外院，大喊着“把巴士底狱交出来，把巴士底狱交出来，把巴士底狱交出来”。他们中的一群人爬上通往内院大门旁边的一家香水店顶部，那里有一座吊桥是关着的，他们割断了固定吊桥的绳子。现在，这就是那种经典的疯狂人群行为，吊桥此时突然打开，非常出人意料，它压死了下面的人。一个人死了，剩下的人群根本不在乎，他们直接跑过吊桥，大概进一步压扁了这个可怜的人。上面有士兵在喊“离远点，离远点，我们不想射杀你们”。人群以为他们在说“进来，进来，我们不会开枪”，所以他们
charge in and the swiss guards start at them. Now the crowd believe, quite wrongly, the people further behind say, oh, they must have lowered the drawbridge and let us into the inner courtyard as a trick because they wanted to shoot us down like dogs. And they go ballistic. The crowd is now stampeding further into the Bastille and the fighting kind of breaks out in earnest. And what then happens, of course, rumors spread. You know, Chinese whispers. People are sort of saying, it's all kicking off at the Bastille. The guards are shooting at our people, at the crowd.
冲了进去，瑞士卫兵开始向他们开火。现在，人群错误地认为，后面的人说，哦，他们一定是放下了吊桥，把我们引诱进内院，因为他们想像狗一样射杀我们。他们彻底疯了。人群现在正冲进巴士底狱，战斗真正爆发了。然后发生的事情，当然，谣言四起。你知道，以讹传讹。人们在说，巴士底狱那边打起来了。卫兵正在向我们的人，向人群开枪。
There's a guy who's called Hulin, Pierre-Augustin Hulin. And he runs out and he gets a load of guards, French guards. And he says, the criminal Delaunay is assassinating our fathers, our wives, and our children. Will you let them be slaughtered? So these Guards Français arrive, and they've brought with them some cannons. And one of those, Tom, is that Siamese cannon.
有一个人叫于兰，皮埃尔-奥古斯丁·于兰。他跑出去，找了一群卫兵，法国卫兵。他说，罪犯德洛奈正在暗杀我们的父亲、妻子和孩子。你们要让他们被屠杀吗？所以这些法国卫兵到了，他们带来了一些大炮。其中一个，汤姆，就是那门暹罗大炮。
Oh, brilliant, with the elephants. Well, the elephants, I think, are a figment of your imagination. But let's imagine it with the elephants, which was a present for Louis XIV, and they aimed these cannons at the gates. So it's total chaos inside the Bastille. Delaunay, the governor, is was a present for Louis XIV, and they aimed these cannon at the gates. So it's total chaos inside the Bastille.
哦，太棒了，还有大象。嗯，大象，我想那是你想象出来的。但让我们想象一下带着大象，那是送给路易十四的礼物，他们把这些大炮对准了大门。所以巴士底狱内一片混乱。德洛奈，总督，是送给路易十四的礼物，他们把这些大炮对准了大门。所以巴士底狱内一片混乱。
De Lorne, the governor, is obviously very distressed at what's happening. Yeah, he's enjoyed a nice breakfast, and now... Yeah, well, he did get his brunch. I mean, Tom,
德洛奈，总督，显然对发生的事情感到非常痛苦。是的，他享受了一顿美妙的早餐，现在……是的，好吧，他确实吃了他的早午餐。我的意思是，汤姆，
it's fair to say the last brunch he'll ever have, sadly. He just wants, basically, the whole thing to be over with honour, and he wants an honourable surrender and no more bloodshed.
公平地说，这是他最后一次早午餐了，可悲的是。他基本上只是想让这一切体面地结束，他想要一次体面的投降，不再有流血事件。
He sends a note to the leaders of the crowd and he says, look, I've got all these barrels of gunpowder. If you don't stop attacking, I will blow up the gunpowder and the fort. I'll blow up the whole thing, right? Sky high. They don't want to give in to this ultimatum. And in fact, his own soldiers say, we don't want you to blow up all the gunpowder and us with it. And so eventually, Delaunay, this wheeze of his has failed. And he says, fine, call it a day.
他给人群的领袖写了一张纸条，他说，看，我有这么多桶火药。如果你们不停止攻击，我就炸掉火药和堡垒。我会把整个东西炸上天，对吧？他们不想屈服于这个最后通牒。事实上，他自己的士兵说，我们不想让你炸掉所有的火药，连同我们一起。所以最终，德洛奈的这个计策失败了。他说，好吧，到此为止吧。
And he lowers the drawbridge that leads to the inner courtyards. The attackers now swarm over this drawbridge. I mean, even though he's basically surrendered and let them in, they're determined to have their sort of moment of glory anyway. So they climb the walls and they hack down the gate, which is a bit kind of unnecessary. And by about five o'clock in the afternoon, the siege is over and there are white flags flying above the Bastille. And they think they are going to find victims of royal despotism chained up in dungeons, do they?
他放下了通往内院的吊桥。袭击者现在蜂拥过这座吊桥。我的意思是，即使他基本上已经投降并让他们进来了，他们还是决心要享受他们的荣耀时刻。所以他们爬上墙，砍倒了大门，这有点多余。到下午五点左右，围攻结束了，巴士底狱上空飘扬着白旗。他们以为他们会发现被锁在地牢里的皇权暴政的受害者，是吗？
Of course they do. I mean, don't forget the Marquis de Sade has been telling them that this massacre was impending yeah and for years as you said going back to voltaire people have believed that the bastille is is rammed with the victims of despotism so how many do they find there are seven people in the bastille tom seven prisoners four of whom are genuine criminals who are forgers who cannot be romanticized at all but they go free do they yeah the forgers do go free, I think. One of them is one of your posh libertines, a guy called the Comte de Solage, who'd been locked up at the request of his own family for bad behavior. And two are lunatics. So of the lunatics, as they are called, one of them is just obviously completely mad. And the other one is probably, some sources say English, some Irish, but I think
当然他们是这么想的。我的意思是，别忘了萨德侯爵一直在告诉他们这场大屠杀即将到来，是的，正如你所说，追溯到伏尔泰，人们一直相信巴士底狱里挤满了暴政的受害者。所以他们发现了多少人？巴士底狱里有七个人，汤姆。七名囚犯，其中四名是真正的罪犯，是伪造者，根本无法被浪漫化。但他们被释放了，是吗？是的，伪造者确实被释放了，我想。其中一个是你的那些时髦的浪荡子之一，一个叫索拉热伯爵的人，他因为行为不端被家人要求关起来。还有两个是疯子。所以，在所谓的疯子中，其中一个显然完全疯了。另一个可能是，一些资料说是英国人，一些说是爱尔兰人，但我认为
it's generally agreed he's Irish. He has a long white beard, doesn't he? Which is good visuals. Yeah. People call him Major White. He looks good. He's the only possible candidate that they have that they can say they've rescued from this massacre, a symbol of liberation, because he's got this beard. And he thinks he's Julius Caesar, doesn't he? Yeah. They put him on their shoulders and carry him around the city. Hurrah, look at this man. Now he thinks he's Julius Caesar, doesn't he? Yeah, they put him on their shoulders and carry him around the city. Hurrah, look at this man. Now he thinks he's Julius Caesar. So he's very confused by the whole thing. He's kind of waving at the crowds.
普遍认为他是爱尔兰人。他有一把长长的白胡子，不是吗？视觉效果很好。是的。人们叫他怀特少校。他看起来不错。他是他们唯一可能的候选人，他们可以说他们从这场大屠杀中拯救了他，一个解放的象征，因为他有这把胡子。他以为他是尤利乌斯·凯撒，不是吗？是的。他们把他扛在肩上，在城市里游行。万岁，看看这个人。现在他以为他是尤利乌斯·凯撒。所以他对这一切感到非常困惑。他一直在向人群挥手。
And I think the next day they take him and lock him up in a lunatic asylum again. So actually, he was probably better off in the Bastille with his fine foods and his billiard table. Anyway, just on the Bastille itself. This is obviously very disappointing from the revolution's point of view. So they have to completely reinvent what happened and what they found. Revolutionary artists pour out prints and engravings that show torture chambers, iron maidens, men in iron masks, all of that kind of stuff. And also the battlements being much, much larger than they really were exactly this extraordinary sort of uh helms deep style siege yeah um which is not really what it was uh they find some bits of old armor in this
我想第二天他们就把他带走，又关进了精神病院。所以实际上，他在巴士底狱里享受着美食和台球桌可能过得更好。总之，关于巴士底狱本身。从革命的角度来看，这显然非常令人失望。所以他们必须彻底重塑发生了什么以及他们发现了什么。革命艺术家们大量印制版画和雕刻，展示酷刑室、铁处女、铁面人等等。还有城垛比实际大得多，完全是这种非凡的“圣盔谷”式的围攻，是的，嗯，这并不是事实，他们在这种
sort of cellar and they bring that out they say torture equipment they find a printing press torture machine all this kind of stuff bastille tourism in the next few days becomes a huge thing. So they basically, former warders turn up. They're giving you a guided tour of the cells. Posh women will have themselves locked in overnight. A really interesting story, and you can read up more about this in a lot of the French Revolution histories. Simon Sharma's really good on this, for example. There was a guy in the crowd who was a building contractor called Pierre-Francois Palloy, and he's very entrepreneurial. He basically gets the contract to demolish the Bastille.
地窖里发现了一些旧盔甲，他们把那些拿出来说这是酷刑设备，他们发现了一台印刷机、酷刑机器等等。巴士底狱旅游在接下来的几天里变得非常热门。所以他们基本上，前看守出现了。他们为你提供牢房的导游服务。时髦的女性会让自己被锁在里面过夜。一个非常有趣的故事，你可以在很多法国大革命的历史书中读到更多。例如，西蒙·夏尔马在这方面写得非常好。人群中有一个建筑承包商叫皮埃尔-弗朗索瓦·帕洛伊，他非常有商业头脑。他基本上拿到了拆除巴士底狱的合同。
He makes tons of money from organizing guided tours, lectures, all this kind of stuff. He builds France's first revolutionary altar from chains and manacles that he claimed to have found in the Bastille. And then he becomes the great entrepreneur of Bastille merchandising. So he puts together a traveling revolution kit that his reps, his sales reps, take to every part of France, every one of the 83 new departments. And it includes a big chest of souvenirs, literally inkwells that are supposedly made from fetters, paperweights in the shape of the Bastille, daggers, snuff boxes. So Dominic, it's very like the way the Berlin Wall,
他通过组织导游、讲座等赚了很多钱。他用他在巴士底狱发现的锁链和手铐建造了法国第一个革命祭坛。然后他成为了巴士底狱周边商品的大企业家。所以他组装了一个旅行革命工具包，他的销售代表把这些带到法国的每个地方，每一个83个新省份。它包括一个装满纪念品的大箱子，字面上是据说是用镣铐制成的墨水瓶、巴士底狱形状的镇纸、匕首、鼻烟盒。所以多米尼克，这很像柏林墙，
you know, the chunks of the Berlin Wall were sold when it came down. Yeah. Enough chunks of the Berlin Wall to make millions of Berlin Walls, I think it's fair to say. It's exactly the same. Yeah yeah it's a cross between medieval relics and basically modern souvenir tat mr palloy's souvenir kits anyway that's the jump ahead let's go back to the afternoon the 14th of july so what happened to all the defenders the swiss guards were initially unharmed because they'd taken their uniforms off so nobody knew who they were some of the avalide are very, very harshly treated. A good example of this is a guy called Beccard.
你知道，柏林墙倒塌时卖出的那些碎片。是的。我想公平地说，柏林墙的碎片多到足以制造数百万个柏林墙。这完全一样。是的，是的，这是中世纪遗物和现代纪念品垃圾的结合体。总之，帕洛伊先生的纪念品工具包，那是后话了。让我们回到7月14日的下午。那么所有守军发生了什么？瑞士卫兵最初没有受到伤害，因为他们脱掉了制服，所以没人知道他们是谁。一些“残疾军人”受到了非常非常严厉的对待。一个很好的例子是一个叫贝卡尔的人。
And this, I think, is quite a scary warning of what lies ahead. Beccard had been one of the key people in dissuading Delaunay from blowing up the gunpowder. So actually, the crowd should have been quite grateful to him. But as soon as they get inside, he opens one of the gates and somebody cuts off his hand. The crowd believe that he must have been a jailer. So they wave his hand around.
我认为，这是一个非常可怕的警告，预示着未来会发生什么。贝卡尔是劝阻德洛奈炸毁火药的关键人物之一。所以实际上，人群应该对他非常感激。但他们一进去，他打开了其中一扇门，有人砍掉了他的手。人群认为他一定是个狱卒。所以他们挥舞着他的手。
And he's presumably still got the keys hanging from the... He's got the key in, yeah, sorry. He's got the key because he's opened the gate. So because of this, they parade around the city carrying this poor bloke's hand. Anyway, he manages to live to the end of the day. But then somebody, again, misidentifies him and says, I think that bloke was one of the guys who was firing the cannons at the people, the day. But then somebody again misidentifies him and says, I think that bloke was one of the guys who was firing the cannons at the people, which he wasn't. And so he ends
他大概还拿着钥匙挂在……他拿着钥匙，是的，抱歉。他拿着钥匙，因为他打开了门。所以因为这个，他们带着这个可怜家伙的手在城市里游行。总之，他设法活到了那天结束。但后来有人，再次误认了他，说，我想那个家伙是向人群开炮的人之一，那天。但后来有人再次误认了他，说，我想那个家伙是向人群开炮的人之一，他其实不是。所以他最终
up being hanged along with some of his comrades, which is very unfortunate, but not as chilling as something that has always stayed in my mind ever since I first read it, which must be 30, 40 years ago, which is what happened to Governor De Launay. Remember I said, he's just a functionary. He wants to kill himself. He was so shamed by the dishonor of surrendering the fortress, but he was stopped from doing so by a grenadier. And the crowd sees on him and they drag him out and they drag him towards the Hôtel de Ville. He's being dragged through the streets. People are spitting on him and kicking him and on all sorts. A horrible scene. They get to the Hôtel de Ville and then they say,
和他的几个战友一起被绞死了，这非常不幸，但不如我第一次读到它时就一直留在脑海里的事情那么令人不寒而栗，那一定是30、40年前的事了，那就是德洛奈总督的遭遇。记得我说过，他只是一个职员。他想自杀。他因为投降堡垒的耻辱而感到非常羞愧，但他被一名掷弹兵阻止了。人群抓住了他，把他拖了出来，拖向市政厅。他被拖过街道。人们向他吐口水、踢他，各种各样。可怕的场景。他们到达市政厅，然后他们说，
let's kill him in a really amusing Baroque way. And there are some people who say, why don't we tie him to a horse's tail and drag him through the city and he will die by being dragged over the cobbles. Because that's the kind of thing that royal executions do to awe and intimidate the masses. And so I suppose there's a kind of element of paying royal officials in their own kind.
让我们用一种非常有趣的巴洛克方式杀了他。有些人说，为什么我们不把他绑在马尾巴上，拖过城市，他就会因为被拖在鹅卵石上而死。因为这就是皇家处决用来敬畏和恐吓大众的方式。所以我猜这有一种以牙还牙的成分。
Exactly. And there's a pastry cook, Deno, who says, no, we'll take him into the city hall, the Hotel de Ville, and we will give him a kind of a trial or something. And to Lorne, who at this point is battered, bruised, covered with blood, crying, whatever, he says, enough of this, let me die.
没错。有一个糕点师，德诺，他说，不，我们把他带进市政厅，我们会给他一个审判之类的。而德洛奈，此时已经伤痕累累、浑身是血、哭泣等等，他说，够了，让我死吧。
And he lashes out furiously and kicks the pastry cook dano in the groin and at that point the crowd kind of closing on him daggers drawn bayonets people are in a frenzy and they stab and stab and stab and kill him poor delaney and then people shoot his body as it lies in the gutter and then somebody gives dano the pastry cook sword and says you have the honor of cutting off his head. And Dano throws the sword aside. I don't need the sword, he says. And he gets out a pocket knife and he then kneels down
他愤怒地猛冲过去，踢了糕点师德诺的腹股沟，就在那一刻，人群围了上来，匕首出鞘，刺刀，人们陷入了疯狂，他们刺啊刺啊刺，杀死了他，可怜的德洛奈，然后人们向躺在阴沟里的尸体开枪，然后有人把糕点师德诺的剑递给他，说，你有砍下他头的荣誉。德诺把剑扔到一边。我不需要剑，他说。他拿出一把折叠刀，然后跪下来
and basically saws this governor's head off. And so this story began with wax heads being paraded. And now... Yeah, and now real heads. And they put his head on a pike. There are women in the crowd, kind of, this is what shocks some witnesses, kind of cheering and singing. And they put his head on a pike. There are women in the crowd, kind of, this is what shocks some witnesses, kind of cheering and singing.
基本上锯下了这位总督的头。所以这个故事开始于蜡像头颅被游行展示。现在……是的，现在是真正的头颅。他们把他的头插在长矛上。人群中有女性，某种程度上，这让一些目击者感到震惊，在欢呼和唱歌。他们把他的头插在长矛上。人群中有女性，某种程度上，这让一些目击者感到震惊，在欢呼和唱歌。
And they parade around. The mayor has been in the Hôtel de Ville all this time, Jacques de Flessel. This is the double-crossing mayor. The people suspect of double-crossing them. They seize him as well. They say afterwards, they found a letter from De Launay in his pocket,
他们四处游行。市长一直都在市政厅，雅克·德·弗莱塞尔。这就是那个两面派市长。人们怀疑他背叛了他们。他们也抓住了他。他们事后说，他们在他的口袋里发现了一封德洛奈的信，
saying, you know, hold out, let's distract the rabble. Whether this is true, we don't know. Of course, there's no evidence for it now. Flessel too was taken outside. He was basically ripped to pieces by the crowd, shot in the head, his head cut off, put on a pike, and then the crowd parade through the streets with his two heads on pikes. So this is what's been happening in the city. That evening it starts to rain and anyone who knows anything about riots and mobs knows that basically the single best way to end a riot is for it to start raining. So like the Chartists in 1848 got rained on and there was no revolution. Yeah so everything has died down in Paris but the National Assembly of course is still in Versailles and that evening
说，你知道，坚持住，让我们分散暴民的注意力。这是否属实，我们不知道。当然，现在没有证据。弗莱塞尔也被带到外面。他基本上被人群撕成了碎片，头部中弹，头被砍下，插在长矛上，然后人群带着他的两个头颅在街上游行。所以这就是城市里发生的事情。那天晚上开始下雨，任何了解骚乱和暴民的人都知道，结束骚乱的最好方法基本上就是开始下雨。就像1848年的宪章派被雨淋了，就没有革命了。是的，所以巴黎的一切都平息了，但国民议会当然还在凡尔赛，那天晚上
as the rain is falling a guy called the Vicomte de noailles bursts into the national assembly in versailles which is hours away ride or whatever and says all this chaos has kicked off in the city and actually the national assembly are not jubilant they are anxious and shocked it is clear to them to some of them even now that this process that they thought they were controlling until a few days ago is spiraling well beyond their ability to restrain it. The king himself has been in the palace all day. That is why in his journal he writes the word, nothing, because it's a hunting journal and he has not done any hunting, which in itself is a sign of how things have changed for him.
当雨落下时，一个叫诺阿耶子爵的人冲进了凡尔赛的国民议会，那是几个小时路程之外，他说城市里发生了这一切混乱，事实上国民议会并不欢欣鼓舞，他们感到焦虑和震惊。对他们中的一些人来说，即使是现在，也很清楚，这个他们以为直到几天前还在控制的过程，正在失控，超出了他们遏制的能力。国王本人整天都在宫殿里。这就是为什么他在日记里写下“无”这个词，因为那是狩猎日记，他没有进行任何狩猎，这本身就是他处境改变的标志。
Yeah, so it's not him being obtuse and failing to recognise the significance of what's happened. No. There's an apocryphal exchange. Somebody comes in to tell him this in the evening, another duke, and tells him the Bastille is for and Louis is supposed to have said, is it a revolt? And the guy said, no, sire, it is a revolution.
是的，所以并不是他迟钝，没有意识到发生的事情的重要性。不。有一个杜撰的对话。那天晚上有人进来告诉他这件事，另一位公爵，告诉他巴士底狱陷落了，路易据说说了，是叛乱吗？那个人说，不，陛下，这是一场革命。
Again, I think that's too Hollywood, really. But the next day, the 15th of July, all morning he dithers and he's not sure what to do, but eventually he decides he should go and address the National Assembly personally he goes in with no guards with no retinue just with his two brothers and he says obviously things in this capital are totally out of control I'm going to withdraw all troops please help me he says help me to assure the salvation of the state help me to send a delegation to Paris to sort things out.
同样，我认为那太好莱坞了。但第二天，7月15日，整个上午他都在犹豫不决，不确定该做什么，但最终他决定应该亲自去向国民议会发表讲话，他没有带卫兵，没有随从，只带了他的两个兄弟，他说显然首都的情况完全失控了，我要撤回所有军队，请帮帮我，他说帮我确保国家的拯救，帮我派一个代表团去巴黎解决问题。
And the deputies are really impressed by this. They're moved by it. They start cheering and brilliant. The king has shown his willingness to work with us, to recognize our importance, and he's clearly going to play decently. So at two o'clock that afternoon, they send this great cortege, this procession of deputies and carriages to Paris. And they are led by the president and the vice president of the National Assembly. The president is an astronomer called Jean-Sylvain Bailly. And the vice president is a man that our American listeners will know, the Marquis de Lafayette. Tremendous character. Do you like the Marquis de Lafayette, Tom? I do. I like him more than you do. I think it's fair to say.
代表们对此印象深刻。他们被感动了。他们开始欢呼，太棒了。国王表现出了与我们合作的意愿，承认了我们的重要性，他显然会表现得体。所以那天下午两点，他们派出了这个盛大的队伍，由代表和马车组成的游行队伍前往巴黎。他们由国民议会的主席和副主席领导。主席是一位叫让-西尔万·巴伊的天文学家。副主席是我们美国听众会认识的人，拉法耶特侯爵。了不起的人物。你喜欢拉法耶特侯爵吗，汤姆？我喜欢。我比你更喜欢他。我想公平地说。
I've got no time for him at all. So he's a rich trustafarian. He's a rich aristocrat. But he's gone off to fight in the American Revolution very bravely. He went for his gap year. Very bravely. And he hangs out with George Washington. And basically, he becomes the son that George Washington never had. Yeah. So Lafayette's 32. He's come back to France from America. He's a massive celebrity.
我一点也不喜欢他。所以他是一个富有的“信托基金宝宝”。他是一个富有的贵族。但他非常勇敢地去参加了美国革命。他去度了间隔年。非常勇敢。他和乔治·华盛顿混在一起。基本上，他成了乔治·华盛顿从未有过的儿子。是的。所以拉法耶特32岁。他从美国回到法国。他是一个巨大的名人。
He's been elected to the Estates General. He's a kind of liberal reformer. Lafayette, very much typical of his generation. I have to say, Tom, his biographers, especially if they're not American and not as keen on him as you are. I wouldn't say I'm keen, but I like his dash and his swagger. One biographer, he biography calls him and i quote vain naive immature and egocentric what's not to like and my favorite one is from the uh which was compiled by french scholars in the 1980s for the bicentenary the entry of lafayette describes him as an empty-headed political dwarf.
他当选为三级会议代表。他是一个自由派改革者。拉法耶特，非常典型的一代人。我必须说，汤姆，他的传记作者，特别是如果他们不是美国人，不像你那么喜欢他。我不会说我喜欢，但我喜欢他的冲劲和气派。一位传记作者称他为，我引用，“虚荣、天真、不成熟和以自我为中心”，有什么不喜欢的呢？我最喜欢的是来自，呃，由法国学者在20世纪80年代为二百周年纪念汇编的，拉法耶特的条目将他描述为“头脑空空的政治侏儒”。
Yeah, I mean, I'm not saying he's a political genius, but he has swagger and dash. Yeah, and you love that. You love a political dwarf. If he dresses well. So they arrive at the Hotel de Ville. Huge cheers, all this kind of stuff. Bailly, the astronomer, people say,
是的，我的意思是，我不是说他是政治天才，但他有气派和冲劲。是的，你喜欢那个。你喜欢政治侏儒。如果他穿得好。所以他们到达了市政厅。巨大的欢呼声，所有这些。巴伊，那位天文学家，人们说，
you be the mayor of Paris now. So he's going to be the mayor of Paris. And Lafayette accepts the command of this new militia, the bourgeois guard, the national guard as it becomes. And it's Lafayette who says, why don't we, as a mark of compromise and the coming together of all these different forces, we will add to the red and blue colors of Paris the white of the Bourbon dynasty. So Dominic, I put it to you. Is this the action of an empty-headed political dwarf? Yeah, it's a terrible flag.
你现在当巴黎市长吧。所以他要当巴黎市长了。拉法耶特接受了这支新民兵，资产阶级卫队，也就是后来的国民自卫队的指挥权。正是拉法耶特说，为什么我们不，作为妥协和所有这些不同力量结合的标志，我们将巴黎的红蓝两色加上波旁王朝的白色。所以多米尼克，我问你。这是头脑空空的政治侏儒的行为吗？是的，这是一面糟糕的旗帜。
Or a man with an eye for political symbolism that has endured to the present day? Well, I mean, it depends what your views on the French flag, Tom. Do you like the old flag, the flag of tradition, honour, and the age-old customs of a proud people? I have a lot of time for the tricolour. Would you like a boring tricolour flag? I don't rate a tricolour flag personally. You know my methods. Anyway, so yeah, this is the origins of the French flag.
还是一个对政治象征意义有眼光，并延续至今的人？嗯，我的意思是，这取决于你对法国国旗的看法，汤姆。你喜欢旧旗帜，传统、荣誉和骄傲人民古老习俗的旗帜吗？我有很多时间喜欢三色旗。你想要一面无聊的三色旗吗？我个人不评价三色旗。你知道我的方法。总之，是的，这就是法国国旗的起源。
The next day, the 16th, so only two days after the fall of the Bastille, the king holds his final ever royal council. His brothers and his relatives, a lot of them have basically now given up on the whole process. Again, they say to him, you should leave. You should get to the frontier. Get loyal troops. This is all out of control.
第二天，16日，也就是巴士底狱陷落仅两天后，国王召开了他最后一次皇家会议。他的兄弟和亲戚，他们中的许多人基本上现在已经放弃了整个过程。他们再次对他说，你应该离开。你应该去边境。找忠诚的军队。这一切都失控了。
But actually, some people say now we're not even sure we can get there in safety, that safety cannot be guaranteed. We just have to somehow stick this out and hope we can turn this around. But Dominic, you know who does go? Tell me. The Duchess de Polignac. Yeah, Marie Antoinette's friend. Marie Antoinette's great friend.
但实际上，有些人说现在我们甚至不确定我们能否安全到达那里，安全无法保证。我们只能设法坚持下去，希望我们能扭转局面。但多米尼克，你知道谁走了吗？告诉我。波利尼亚克公爵夫人。是的，玛丽·安托瓦内特的密友。玛丽·安托瓦内特的好朋友。
And who doesn't go is our other great friend, the Princess de Lamballe. I know. Should have gone. Should have gone, Tom. Princess de Lamballe. Yeah. As events will prove. As events will prove.
而没走的是我们的另一位好朋友，朗巴勒亲王妃。我知道。应该走的。应该走的，汤姆。朗巴勒亲王妃。是的。正如事件将证明的那样。正如事件将证明的那样。
So quite a lot of them do go that night. The Comte d'Artois, the Prince de Conti, the Prince de Condé. So these are the first émigré. So for the first time, you have people now fleeing France for the frontiers, determined that there will be no compromise with the revolution. But Louis himself does not flee. He instead, the following day, the 17th, makes an extraordinary gesture. He decides to go to Paris himself in an undecorated carriage wearing a plain undecorated coat. And he is greeted at the gates of Paris by the new mayor, Bailly, the astronomer from the National Assembly. And Bailly
所以那天晚上确实有很多人走了。阿图瓦伯爵、孔蒂亲王、孔代亲王。所以这些是第一批流亡者。所以第一次，你有了人们现在为了边境逃离法国，决心不与革命妥协。但路易本人没有逃跑。相反，第二天，17日，他做出了一个非凡的姿态。他决定亲自去巴黎，坐在一辆没有装饰的马车里，穿着一件朴素的、没有装饰的外套。他在巴黎城门口受到了新市长巴伊的迎接，那位来自国民议会的天文学家。巴伊
hands him the keys of the city. And he says, these are the same keys that were presented to Henri IV, Henry IV, a great folk hero to the French people, the king who had abandoned Protestantism because he said, Paris is worth a mass, is it? Paris is worth a mass. Also, he's very keen that every peasant should have a chicken in a pot. Exactly. Everybody loves him. Chickens and Catholicism.
把城市的钥匙交给了他。他说，这些是当年献给亨利四世的同样的钥匙，亨利四世，法国人民心目中的伟大民间英雄，那位放弃了新教的国王，因为他说，“巴黎值得一场弥撒”，是吗？巴黎值得一场弥撒。此外，他非常热衷于每个农民都应该有一只锅里的鸡。没错。每个人都爱他。鸡肉和天主教。
And Bailly says to Louis, these keys were given to Henry IV. He had conquered his people, but now it is his people who have conquered their king I mean who wants to hear that? Yeah Louis must have loved that Poor Louis like smiling weakly Anyway Lafayette is there with his new cockade
巴伊对路易说，这些钥匙曾交给亨利四世。他征服了他的子民，但现在是他的子民征服了他们的国王。我的意思是，谁想听这些？是的，路易一定很喜欢这个。可怜的路易，只能虚弱地微笑。总之，拉法耶特带着他的新帽徽在那里
the new colours red, white and blue Looking tremendous I'm sure There are loads of national guards now lining the streets they process through the streets market women dressed in white
新颜色是红、白、蓝。我相信看起来非常棒。现在有大量的国民警卫队在街道两旁列队，他们穿过街道，市场上的妇女身穿白衣
making up the rear of the procession. We'll be hearing more about market women, I imagine, in the next couple of days. We will, yeah. And people are chanting, not long live the king, but long live the nation, la nation. They get to the city hall and there there's a great banner, Louis XVI, father of the French, the king of a free people.
走在游行队伍的最后。我想，接下来的几天里我们会听到更多关于这些市场妇女的消息。是的，我们会听到的。人们高呼的不是国王万岁，而是民族万岁，法兰西民族万岁。他们到达市政厅，那里有一条巨大的横幅，写着路易十六，法国人之父，自由人民的国王。
And Dominic Quay there, he's not described as the king of France. So the idea that France is the property of the king of a free people. And Dominic Key there is, he's not described as the king of France. So the idea that France is the property of the king is gone. Yes, exactly. Louis gets onto a throne and people make speeches and he's said to have listened with tears running down his cheeks. Of course, some people say, wonderful, tears of patriotic pride.
多米尼克·奎在那里，他没有被描述为法国国王。所以，法国是国王财产的观念，即自由人民的国王，已经不复存在了。是的，正是如此。路易坐上王位，人们发表讲话，据说他听着听着，泪水顺着脸颊流了下来。当然，有些人说，太棒了，这是爱国自豪的泪水。
Others say he's gutted. It's just like the worst day of his life. Bailly gives him a tricolour cockade, red, white and blue, and the king sticks in his hat and everybody cheers. But what he is thinking, we don't know. We know he got back to Versailles that night about 10 o'clock and Marion Swinette and his family were so worried about him. But what he said to them, what he made of it all remains a mystery. Most people though at the time thought this was a truly exceptional event in history. One third estate deputy, a guy called Jean-Antoine Huguet, said it was unique in the annals of the universe to see a
另一些人说他心碎了。这就像他一生中最糟糕的一天。巴伊给了他一个红、白、蓝三色的三色帽徽，国王把它插在帽子上，每个人都欢呼雀跃。但他心里在想什么，我们不得而知。我们知道他那天晚上10点左右回到了凡尔赛，玛丽·安托瓦内特和他的家人非常担心他。但他对他们说了什么，他对这一切有什么看法，仍然是一个谜。不过，当时大多数人认为这是历史上真正非凡的事件。一位第三等级的代表，一个叫让-安托万·于盖的人，说在宇宙的编年史上，看到一个
people that had taken up arms against their king now reunited with their king in a world in which the balance of power completely changed. He says, it was reserved for the French nation to give this example to the universe. And that universalism, we'll be talking about this tomorrow when you get onto the sort of ideological shift that the French Revolution represents. That universalism is so key to this whole story. There's a great source for this whole period, the letters of a bookseller called Nicolas Rouault. And he wrote to his brother after this.
曾经拿起武器反对国王的人民，现在与他们的国王重新团聚，在一个权力平衡完全改变的世界里，这是独一无二的。他说，法兰西民族注定要给宇宙树立这个榜样。这种普遍主义，我们明天会讨论，当你谈到法国大革命所代表的意识形态转变时。这种普遍主义是整个故事的关键。关于这一时期，有一个很好的来源，就是一位名叫尼古拉斯·鲁奥的书商的信件。他在事后写信给他的兄弟。
He said, everything will now change. Morals, opinions, laws, customs, usages, government. In very little time, we will be new men. And that, of course, is the French Revolution's appeal, the idea of starting anew and making you know a better world but actually tom it would be to be birkian i think it would be wrong to end on the note of optimism because actually the violence doesn't end with the fall of the bastille something has been unleashed now i would say and i know this is just my own prejudice talking but i would say something has
他说，一切都将改变。道德、舆论、法律、习俗、用法、政府。在很短的时间内，我们将成为新人。当然，这就是法国大革命的吸引力所在，即重新开始并创造一个更美好世界的想法。但实际上，汤姆，我认为以乐观的基调结束是不对的，因为暴力并没有随着巴士底狱的陷落而结束。现在有些东西已经被释放出来了，我想说，我知道这只是我个人的偏见，但我会说有些东西
been unleashed that cannot now be put back in its box. And the example of this is what we began with. So seven days, one week after the fall of the Bastille, the food prices are still very high. And there are rumors that an official, a royal official in the war ministry called Joseph Foulon de Douai had said about the poor, let them eat straw. Whether he did say it, we do not know. A crowd grabbed him. They hanged him, they cut off his head, they stuffed grass and straw in his mouth, and they paraded his head around the city on a pike. And then they saw his son-in-law, who was the intendant of Paris, the royal official
已经被释放出来，现在无法再关回盒子里了。这方面的例子就是我们开始时提到的。所以，在巴士底狱陷落七天后，也就是一周后，食品价格仍然非常高。有传言说，战争部的一位官员，名叫约瑟夫·富隆·德·杜埃，曾对穷人说，让他们吃草。他是否真的说过，我们不得而知。一群人抓住了他。他们绞死了他，割下了他的头，把草和稻草塞进他的嘴里，然后用长矛挑着他的头在城市里游行。然后他们看到了他的女婿，也就是巴黎的总监，那位负责巴黎的皇家官员
responsible for Paris, who was Berthier de Sauvigny, the man you began with. And they grabbed him and they forced him to accompany them around the streets. They held the head of Foulon in front of him, his father-in-law, and they chanted at him, kiss papa, kiss papa. I mean, an absolutely unbelievably horrendous scene. They got to the city hall, they killed Berthier. They literally tore the heart out of his body and threw it at the walls of the city hall. And then they put his head on a pike too, alongside his father-in-law's and paraded it around. And that newspaper you mentioned, Élysée Lustelot's Révolution de Paris, he wrote a big article about this.
也就是贝蒂埃·德·索维尼，你一开始提到的那个人。他们抓住了他，强迫他陪着他们在街上走。他们把富隆（他的岳父）的头举在他面前，对他高喊，亲吻爸爸，亲吻爸爸。我的意思是，一个绝对令人难以置信的恐怖场景。他们到达市政厅，杀死了贝蒂埃。他们从他的身体里掏出了心脏，扔在市政厅的墙上。然后他们也把他的头插在长矛上，和岳父的头放在一起游行。你提到的那份报纸，埃利泽·吕斯特洛的《巴黎革命》，他写了一篇关于这件事的大文章。
That's what we quoted. And Lustelot said, it's fine. They were both traitors to the nation, traitors to the people. And actually it's only by killing such people that Frenchmen, you will be free. And as Simon Sharma says in his book, Citizens, this isn't the end of something. This is just the beginning. And he says, when he's described
这就是我们引用的内容。吕斯特洛说，这很好。他们两人都是民族的叛徒，人民的叛徒。实际上，只有通过杀死这样的人，法国人，你们才能获得自由。正如西蒙·沙马在他的书《公民》中所说，这并不是某件事的结束。这仅仅是个开始。他说，当他描述
these events, violence was not just an unfortunate side effect of the French Revolution. It was the revolution's source of collective energy. It was violence that made the revolution revolutionary. And I'm afraid there will be a lot more violence to come. But I think worth mentioning as well, there will also be a lot more idealism and abstract nouns to come. And in tomorrow's episode, we'll look at the ideals that enthusiasts for the revolution are promoting. And one of the most significant texts ever written, the Declaration of the Rights of Man and the Citizen, been an inspiration across the world.
这些事件时，暴力不仅仅是法国大革命的一个不幸的副作用。它是革命集体能量的源泉。正是暴力使革命具有了革命性。恐怕未来还会有更多的暴力。但我认为也值得一提的是，未来还会有更多的理想主义和抽象名词。在明天的节目中，我们将看看革命的热情支持者们所宣扬的理想。以及有史以来最伟大的文献之一，《人权和公民权宣言》，它激励了全世界。
And we will be looking at that and seeing where the French Revolution is heading ideologically in the wake of the fall of the Bastille. So we will see you then. Brilliant. Bye-bye. Bye-bye. and on entertainment and we tell you how it all works. We have just launched our Members Club. If you want ad-free listening,
我们将审视这一点，看看法国大革命在巴士底狱陷落后在意识形态上走向何方。所以我们到时见。太棒了。再见。再见。关于娱乐，我们告诉你它是如何运作的。我们刚刚推出了我们的会员俱乐部。如果你想要无广告收听，
bonus episodes and early access to live tickets, head to therestisentertainment.com There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
奖励剧集和提前获得现场门票，请前往 therestisentertainment.com。本集目前还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。